ça va très bien et toi bah écoute ça va
ça va j'ai pas été réveillé cinq fois
par ma fille ce soir cette nuit donc
tout va bien j'espère que tu es en forme
pour cette quatrième ronde du tada style
toujours toujours
en forme après ça sera plus compliqué
comme hier en tout cas on va voir
comment ça se passe donc on a des pas
mal de petits appareillons bien sympas
là je viens de les voir alors je vais
vous les montrer regardez bien sur le
chat donc on a du coup Wesley SOC contre
Aronian on a Kemer contre irrigazie on a
dingly Rennes
j'ai fermé une fenêtre désolé
on a Dingle contre pragdaland
qui est d'ailleurs en tête du tournoi
pourrait prendre encore un peu d'avance
sur Pasanda
qu'on va essayer de suivre dans cette
partie voir un petit peu si Guiri essaie
de de jeux pour le gain avec les Blancs
on a besoin de Rohff contre matso de
l'eau
et rapport carvana donc dans cette
tronçon ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup en fait de duels si
tu veux tu vois on a déjà expérimenté
qui se jouent donc saut à Rognard
et après on a une seule partie où
vraiment tu as un ancien cette ligne
contre un jeune praganda et toutes les
autres c'est vraiment des jeunes qui
s'affrontent tu vois on a Kemer réghasi
on a 12 octobre contre mcdoslo et on
avant de Forest contre donc une ronde
qui peut être très simple
la France
et à bientôt
non plus c'est trop long tu vois les
gens qu'on demande
donc pourquoi je dirais pas pareil
voilà ok ça marche donc de beaux
appariement ici
Carlson en fait on a un doute en fait
moi j'ai goûté l'interview de guéri il a
dit oui pour que ça soit une partie
fight pour que les deux on voient
[Musique]
4 bon je pense qu'une nul c'est un très
bon résultat pour guéri c'est pas un
mauvais état pour Carlsen qui allait
dans un qui va subir
mais bon voilà moi je pense que ça va
faire nulle très vite
tu as même guéri je peux la du monde il
avait des options enfin tu vois
accompagnement de
blés
sans jouer en même en blitz alors
dès qu'il a une partie importante il
fait sa petite nulle
c'est comme
comme Naka quoi tu demandes mais est-ce
que tu veux ton tour du monde quoi tu
vois
en tête et après il était censé avoir
des apparemment plus facile ce qui était
pas faux dans The Box ça aucun sens et
dès qu'il remonte il fait nul mais
en tout cas voilà guéri je après on sait
pas aussi bien il va il va vraiment
vouloir la coller à carcennes il va tout
faire et faire Rollin mais franchement
j'y crois absolument pas voilà c'est
digne avec les Blancs
j'ai envie qu'il fasse un bon tournoi
pour se chauffer avant le match de
champion du monde
Prague Prague en plus on a trouvé un peu
naïf même si hier il a fait quand même
plutôt une bonne partie
là il aurait mérité mieux presque un
petit peu raté sur la fin mais il avait
fait une partie
au début puis c'est bien défendu la fin
il est dur à battre
mais oui tu es mal dans l'ouverture et
toi les deux en fait on joue bien joué à
une phase de jeu différente et donc en
tout cas avant la Prague et les Noirs
contre un joueur par contre le numéro de
mondial quoi donc c'est pour lui c'est
un gros test et Jim ben il a les blancs
quand un genre beaucoup moins fort donc
pour lui c'est l'occasion de pouvoir
marquer un point et essayer de prendre
un peu de distance sur des sur les
poursuivants donc une partie en tout cas
hyper intéressante on va tout regarder
on aura le temps de faire aujourd'hui
après tu veux dire rapporte carvana
rapporte qui a l'air un peu cagoulé mais
qui a besoin de se refaire car on a qu'à
gagner hier tu peux gagner avec le noir
je pense il va pas s'en priver ça
abdouille
parce que Abdou quand il réfléchis il a
les blancs si tu dois gagner une partie
tu as envie de te dire c'est sans doute
qu'on parle non
il va essayer du coller soit rognan je
m'attends à une partie chiante une
partie solide ils ont joué ensemble
ne va pas m'intéresser trop j'espère
beaucoup c'est un gros il y a une gros
vraiment
un gros
passif
entre eux aussi ouais voilà puisque
son circuit je pense qu'ils sont dans le
plein de fois aussi mais bon ok
ça peut être hyper sympa encore une fois
faut voir l'ouverture caméra mais il a
quand même très bien pareil il a bien
préparé il a des idées
vente Forez va danser ouais c'est plus
il est parti entre les jeunes
elle est blanche qu'on goûter ce qui est
très facile à préparer vous cache
plusieurs fois et les deux fois où j'ai
eu les blancs je l'ai attrapé entre
guillemets bien sûr
donc
merci pour humeur du lundi qui me
félicite pour la vidéo comme tous les
jours je fais une vidéo résumé sur Blist
stream
donc hier vidéo sur la partie de carvana
contre vent forest
ouais c'est ça et bah il y avait pas
trop le choix c'était la seule partie
en plus elle était assez correcte c'est
sympa j'ai bien aimé la partie
il y a eu des erreurs mais bon ça fait
partie
Kevin à tweeter que sa fille était née
ce matin
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ma vidéo
toute seule enfin j'ai fait la vidéo
tout seul ok
Sophie abordi alors moi je savais
qu'elle allait s'appeler Sofia c'est un
prénom qui est hyper crépendu c'est
hyper la moi d'un je trouve
en France
[Musique]
et les Sofia il y en a pas mal je trouve
c'est
en tout cas autour de moi j'entends
souvent sur le prénom mais c'est c'est
[Rires]
félicitations à lui un peu de repos
après il m'a dit que peut-être ce soir
il allait streamer ça dépendait
l'euphorie du truc
après
une sorte de forêt vraiment je tiens à
l'hôpital mais je sais que lui il a
prévu de pas y rester ok
est-ce qu'il va faire le pense pas que
je pense plus il voudrait être en mode
chill et parler te dire qu'il est
content pour aller aux gens à la commune
je le vois pas ce soir
il faut qu'il prenne la semaine ouais
moi je lui dis de en plus pour les
vidéos je m'en occupe cette semaine je
lui dis il y a pas de souci
ouais bah qui va faire le TT il m'a dit
OK
alors les joueurs s'installent ouais
donc ça va commencer dans une minute
enfin déjà commencé en fait mais je vous
rappelle qu'on a toujours un petit
retard et du coup on va commencer d'ici
quelques secondes je pense
Nantes alors Mathieu il est là que
aujourd'hui enfin il était là hier et
aujourd'hui
demain ce jour de repos et après on aura
on aura plusieurs invités différentes
notamment le dernier où moi je serai pas
là
et après faut que je regarde
tous les jours ce genre aurait peut-être
pu en faire un autre mais bon il faut
que tu vois avec avec Sam ou avec Nathan
je pense parce que
m'avait envoyé un planning
je crois qu'il y a il me semble qu'il
reste de date je peux te la donner ce
qu'ils vont en direct
tu m'envoies un message je te dirai si
je peux ou pas
moi j'ai un tableau on voit pas bien
on a un coup
et on a des quatre
[Musique]
jours mais j'y crois pas contre Guiri tu
joues pas la grande folle
à de la salle mais la selle tu vois ah
oui non mais en fait moi je regardais
sur la mauvaise caméra c'est vrai qu'on
voit des murs chelous avec des pièces
d'échec ok donc je comprenais pas moi je
regardais l'autre caméra c'est pas la
bonne OK
salut Steph donc le mec il me dit pas
bonjour ok ça va
par contre pas la majuscule bonjour
quand même juste voilà il manque le
respect
même pour le hâte
[Musique]
comme il l'a joué l'autre jour
bah non c'est pas lui qui l'a joué mais
on en a parlé hier pendant
il joue non ok deuxième moi cette année
du tournoi
mais j'ai pas la cam sur cam je regarde
j'ai mis à droite pour voir ce que tu
ok il joue exactement la ligne qui a
joué digne d'ailleurs fois 6 du coup
ouais donc la B3 audame C2 moi il existe
aussi dans ma carte et dans MP3
évidemment mais ok dames et deux c'est
la grosse ligne avec de service depuis
en dessin
pourquoi un nom par OSN en fait le reste
indienne on la joue plus 3 au niveau
parce que c'est un peu compliqué mais du
coup ça donne des parties fight moi j'ai
une époque je l'ai joué j'en ai perdu
deux donc godzilli et strates
mais sinon j'en ai gagné plein
par rapport à des ragazzi où j'ai fait
beaucoup beaucoup de nuls West indienne
j'ai gagné vraiment beaucoup de parties
c'est plus fight en fait OK
donc du coup l'idée principale Mathieu
ici
donc dame C2 qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer
ici c'est
quoi
aucun des deux ok
[Musique]
changer d'égaliser et là le bon coup
c'est des 5 puis on prend puis on prend
cavalier prend
rock et vous avez quelque chose
et c'est très théorique il y a des
parties de Alpha zéro en 707 = mais les
noirs doivent bien connaître
je ça prouve que tu regardes pas mes
vidéos mais bon c'est pas grave si tu
joues direct
puis on prend puis on prend ok ici tu
peux pas jouer ok prends et qui H4 qui
gagne une pièce
et si tu prends du fou qui est proposé
dans le chat et il a raison en fait que
ça soit avec la dame en CD ou pas avec
la dame C2 en fait je vais jouer vite
casser 3 E4 et en fait tu perds trop de
temps
il y a des trous en dessin qu'en D6 je
vais rocker je vais faire du E5 non
c'est pas une catalane c'est non le
catalan le pion est toujours en D5 là il
en 17
donc du coup l'idée de fois assis c'est
ça c'est provoqué soit dame soit B3 même
s'il existe d'autres coups ce que je
disais
et donc l'idée de provoquer d'un pseudo
c'est ça c'est de repère un temps pour
pouvoir jouer ce C5 et se proche
d'égaliser
et si B3 c'est la partie que j'ai
commenté l'autre jour que tu as commandé
aussi le Nord ont joué avec des cintres
rapidement et les jeux fous aussi
d'abord je crois
c'était la partie cache
la partie C3
qui est pas meilleur normalement
normalement le plus joué c'est plutôt
prise des cinq dame c'est deux fois
quatre et je vais tranquille comme ça
oui c'est vrai que on espère aussi que
les parties aujourd'hui va être plus
funky je pense que
[Musique]
comme il a été surpris
là il réfléchit laquelle j'aurais donc
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
c'est que là comme il est surpris je
m'attends pas le voir jouer la vente la
plus charte sauf si par hasard il l'a
révisé il y a pas longtemps
là c'est pas qui connaît pas c'est la
personne la mieux préparée sur Terre
une des personnes je le mettrai dans le
top 3
depuis le matin
juste tout ok bah donc là il réfléchit
donc moi j'ai peur qu'il joue une petite
ligne et qui est pas grand-chose mais
bon ça peut être intéressant
au niveau des ouvertures
ah oui c'est vrai
et puis des cinq pour pas que le foie en
B2
[Musique]
donc là
cavalier à 5 de pas encore être trop
dangereux
trois ou à quatre normalement
l'espace l'ancien coup c'était alors ça
c'est une question que je connais parce
que je l'ai joué avec les deux couleurs
A4 il y a plusieurs couples soit 6 soit
petit rock
[Musique]
alors petit rock ça toujours le défaut
de laisser fou G5
ça l'avantage de menacer kygi G4 alors
faut G5 ça donne des lignes assez
compliquées avec H i5 bien sûr
on en a parlé avec le pion A5
exactement ça
d'un côté les Noirs ont dû faire à 5 on
les Blancs ont dû faire à 4 ont perdu un
temps mais par contre ils ont B4 et
cette expansion de la dame qui est
intéressante pour eux c'est la partie
pour l'instant parce qu'après
instructif allez je t'apprendre quelque
chose si tu fais par rock
avec les Noirs si tu fais un schiste
j'ai pas eu besoin de jouer H3 ok si tu
me fais rock
c'est le coup de la partie tu dois jouer
à
ça c'est pas la même type de position
parce que si tu fais quelle idée de ici
il y a le truc qu'on avait mentionné
hier que ça faisait longtemps
les deux donne un bon jeu
donc si je prends encore une fois on a
parlé hier il y a prise il y a des
problèmes sur les trois qui arrivent
aussi vu qu'il y a un clouage avec des
Mach4
du coup H3 jouets dans la partie et donc
là il y a deux façons de jouer en ce
moment c'est soit à
cause
de deux fois au candidat
une fois avec H6 en plus par un diabov
et une fois 100 par car on a perdu mais
c'est censé je pense que ça va pour
l'instant alors la différence avec à 5
encore une fois c'est que avec le pion à
5 tu as le fou B5 hier on l'a vu par
rame il a joué sur fosse
tu as besoin que je fouette tu laisses à
4 mais t'empêche faut baisser un autre
toi chaque coup un avantage un
inconvénient et donc du coup si tu fais
faut prendre ici
puis on prend à 6
il y a deux façons de jouer pour le
blanc soit tu fais B4
et l'idée de faire tour à deux
sur quoi les Noirs vont jouer avec
cavalier H5 d'un F6
ou dames 8
[Musique]
il y avait eu un match alors je sais
plus en quoi c'était il me semble qu'il
y avait mvl double qui avait pas mal
cette position je me trompe peut-être
à la place de Beckett
à la place de B4 ici X3 et un collo
logique comme on n'a pas joué des deux
on profite
pour prendre
et là le nouveau coup entre guillemets
entreduit par un
avec l'idée
puis on prend cavalier prend
et tu veux qu'il y avait les quatre
ok cette pollution
est-ce que c'est exactement la même ça
ressemble pas mal dans la dans la
structure
on a eu le même position depuis 1 2 puis
on a 5 il a freinage de D5
et donc reviens à la base puis on prend
des cinq si tu fais qu'il y ait des deux
l'idée c'est des quintes
et là c'est hyper surprenant le meilleur
coup c'est genre tout droit et de donner
le plan des trois
voilà
OK et tout voilà du coup tu donnes trois
et c'est grave
mieux toi c'est genre 10 c'est 15 voilà
donc ça tombe bien que je connais bien
comment comment il joue Ding la priori
il faut manger comme tu disais
alors moi j'avais regardé mais c'était
avec un pion à 5 avec un pion à 5 un
coup comme B3 et pas déconnant le sol
défaut de B3 c'est que tu as
du dessin qui va arriver
en autre option ça serait cahier des
deux hein
6 il y a plein de coups qui ont l'air
cohérent et
donc voilà Ding
[Musique]
bon je suis curieux de voir parce que
c'est une ligne que je considère comme
bonne pour les Noirs
tous les bons coups ça je prends juste
c'est une des lignes que les noirs
peuvent égaliser ok ça marche
[Musique]
je connais très bien même parce que j'ai
joué ça
et fougère c'est le nouveau coup
accélérée et en fait j'ai fait un match
alors je sais pas pour les jettes ouais
cornet en bulleton voilà il y a des mecs
qui ont la rêve dans le chat c'est ce
que j'ai jeu contre un bulleton dans mon
match sur internet pour H4 G5 donc il y
a des parties il y a même une partie une
Carlson nepo sur ça et H5 menace de
gagner le fou H4 c'est pas le seul coup
mais c'est logique qui avait le 4 là il
y a plusieurs coups qui avait lieu et
fougère c'était une nouveauté au niveau
en fait c'est un coup qui a été joué par
ordinateur
dans une partie et donc c'était mon
match contre un bulleton sauf que
j'avais pas le droit de réviser entre
les trucs l'idée c'est que si tu fais F3
je prends un G3 et je reviens repart on
le 6 disons il y a pas qu'elle prend un
chien parce que tu es un pion F3
ok donc du coup moi il m'a joué dans le
B3 chaque fois OK
et en fait j'ai joué deux fois qui est
ici ce qui est une faute OK et du coup à
la fin du deuxième set j'ai pu regarder
mon fichier
et j'ai joué le bon coup j'ai joué qui
est projet
qui éponge 3 et 6
pour B5
faut prendre ces trois
dans
et oui j'avais gagné en méthode j'avais
pas vu le premier set en dominant
c'était assez bizarre et après j'ai
gagné assez facile les 2e et 3e 7 je
crois quand tout il y a eu 11,5
forest le frère dans un rapide où
j'avais complètement égalisé puis après
une grosse connerie foutue puis après
c'est nul j'ai perdu mais il m'avait pas
joué dans mes trois
non il avait pas joué qui avait lieu je
pense
G4 c'est le nouveau compte en fait c'est
un coup qui a été introduit par
ordinateur
ok
le bon coup c'était MP3 mon coup
principal dans mon fichier c'est ce que
m'avait joué en Belton sauf que j'avais
pas j'ai mis trois parties à trouver le
bon truc la première fois
j'ai gagné je pense la partie derrière
mais
[Musique]
ici il y a un truc il y a un truc
hallucinant parce que je veux me
rappeler
qu'est-ce que tu veux réussir avec les
bancs
c'est ça
d'accord il faut prendre F3 c'était la
partie donc là on était tous les deux en
un pro total il m'a repris d'en prendre
en rock j'ai bouffé H1 j'ai gagné la
partie mais en fait il pouvait faire
intermédiaire AG6 hg5 je crois
et c'est censé être un peu mieux pour
les blancs dans une très compliqué donc
pour éviter ça il faut prendre en G3
d'abord
ok ça marche
complexe
et donc du coup dans la position coup
d'avant si tu fais fois 2 direct
ah il me faut je dirais que j'attaque
ces trois donc c'est ça donc c'est ça
il attaque tu es obligé de bouger la
dame c'est le plus logique quand même
ça me fait ça un jour avant le début du
stream
sur streaming
alors le problème de cette ligne c'est
que du coup je l'ai joué plusieurs fois
tu fais une erreur tu peux perdre vite
ça peut être bien de bien côté
ouvertures tu vois mais de l'autre côté
ça peut être dangereux donc ça c'est
vraiment je pense réservé surtout
aux professionnels aux joueurs qui sont
plus simple
roté de jouer la Roch Voisine malgré un
ordre de coups qui normalement le permet
pas du coup il y a plus d'inconvénients
les inconvénients c'est de ce type de
variante que l'ordinateur fait tenir
mais qui est stratégiquement est dur à
justifier
et ma femme l'a joué elle aurait dû
faire une contre Alberto David pardon
les parties ça me dérange pas je connais
bien
ce il nous reste quoi donc Abdou
donc c'est encore
[Musique]
ok ça m'intéresse toujours ce truc
et souvent les blancs dans l'idée de
rejoindre des quatre après
on nous dit c'est peut-être une
extension du navigateur avec vérifie que
tu as pas une extension
ok donc espagnol
ah non Cyril je suis pas le mieux
préparé
pas le mieux préparé du tout du monde
mais la différence avec pas mal de mecs
qui commentent c'est comme j'ai des
élèves
qui joue des choses différentes je
connais un peu de tout parce que je veux
dire
c'est il y en a ils vont connaître soit
leur ligne à la perfection leur vie de
l'air tu le prends sur la grande fold
de mon niveau je sais pas qui on
pourrait prendre mais
j'ai l'avantage de comme j'ai des gens
entraîne beaucoup je vois différents
trucs
alors donc celle là du coup
j'ai joué aussi
qui avait joué ça et Ding gagne souvent
des positions comme ça avec les parents
c'est très très solide
B3 je t'aime pour ok c'est à dire qu'il
connaît
voilà le résultat de c'est quoi c'est
que la position est simplifiée les
blancs dans le petit avantage de
développement la question c'est est-ce
que ça va suffire ou pas
je serais pas complètement surpris ouais
qui sont dans le circuit depuis très
longtemps qui sont plein de fois c'est
un peu moins compatible je pense que
quelqu'un dit par exemple
avoir
je regardais partie d'ordi aussi très
souvent c'est vrai surtout que là on va
essayer de faire une mensuelle
pour que je commande des parties d'ordi
tous les mois
intéressant mais ça peut vite pas bien
donc là on a un petit
OK
il a voulu jouer C5 c'est objectivement
un bon coup parce qu'on peut ne pas
avoir peur de décès
décès qui peut faire peur d'ailleurs
disons B4
et c'est une sorte de position avec un
temps très cool inverse disons à 5 c'est
j'ai joué ça c'est 5 je l'ai déjà contre
Freyssinet au départage au France OK
mais bon je devais j'avais besoin de
gagner j'ai été un peu mieux mais moi
normalement non
je ne connais pas
désolé les gars moi j'ai pas la réponse
non moi non plus parce qu'à la limite B3
tu vois c'est l'alcool tu vois donc tu
as les trucs un petit peu
non mais en fait OK
remets la position au premier coup
au premier pour le dernier s'il te plaît
D4D
et 4 6
et ces trois
qui est 6 KLF 3 ok là il y a fu F4 sont
les coups le plus logique et le Cool
biologique pour les noirs
là c'est une mer rang avec un temps de
plus à 3
donc à 3 son idée c'est des Français B4
C4
par exemple
avant de manger en 5 à Mathieu on attend
que le fou sorte
parce que si je mange directement c'est
5 il a mangé du fou comme ça et souvent
en fait on va attendre que le foot
je suis complètement choqué
21 secondes
mais c'est vrai que ça c'est bizarre
parce que ce que fait gamer c'est quand
même
pour donner cette option de C4 qui est
C3 il joue A3 avec l'idée de prendre
B3 tu peux plus reprendre depuis moi
et là il a fait A4 et donc là les deux
réfléchissent donc ça c'est quand même
c'est lunaire c'est parti
c'est très bizarre
on a fini on connaissait tous les deux
jusqu'à la fin donc on a discuté de la
ligne et tout et après je lui dis
est-ce que tu vas à la bermuda partie
il me dit bah c'est normalement j'ai pas
le droit c'est jusqu'à 20 ans non et
après ils ont changé ma règlement
c'était pas le droit de boire quant à
moins de 21 mais tu avais le droit d'y
aller quand tu as plus de 18 et un
moment qui je veux arriver sur la piste
de danse hyper à fond et là il est ici
je l'aime beaucoup le garçon il est haut
dans mon estime pour l'instant
et du coup il était comment comment il
se sentait
à l'aise
ça doit quelque chose de le voir sur la
piste de danse lui qui a l'air un petit
peu un petit peu timide quoi quand même
alors avant de Forest
donc ça c'est la ligne à la mode les
donc la kb5
soit on fait pousser 500
qui est prince ici celui de 5 à 2 c'est
un petit coup
bienvenu que je suis pas hyper expert
en ce qui est
déjà joué mais normalement il y a
fubécat qui est censé être critique
avec l'idée de taper le pion 1 4
mais l'idée souvent c'est de le donner
à Calvi en 2009
et du coup parce que je donne des trois
parce que est-ce que tu te rappelles de
la partie car on a guéri première ronde
phase retour des candidats
donc la réponse est pas claire non à la
place de fodée
nouvelle idée
et donc du coup quand tu vois cette
position tu te dis ben pourquoi pas dans
la partie la plus besoin de jouer à 3
voilà raisonnement ou pas
besoin de jouer de jouer à 6
donc cette position existe sur la Roser
avec le fond de 5 mais là il y est pas
donc là il y a quoi comme couleur
et soit fouet 4 quelque chose comme ça
se regarde on va dire je sais pas si
c'est formé ça se regarde sinon quoi
d'autre fois F4 dans la même idée de ce
que je viens de dire
il faut G5 ok on sent qu'il va falloir
c'est un peu bizarre parce que tu peux
montrer une rose heure
donc
[Musique]
tu reviens de quoi avant
disons
des 4 cahier 5 E6 et ici il y a un
nouveau coup entre guillemets à la mode
ces dames des trois
que j'ai joué à la première onde de
Reykjavik open 2022 mon adversaire a
joué à 6 qui est douteux parce qu'il y a
qui est prend celle-ci c'est grand rock
et j'ai commenté la partie elle est sur
Youtube avec l'idée fois deux dame et du
coup le bon coup sur Dame des trois
vous l'avez sans doute vu ça il faut des
7 tu as été joué par Google
Bacro contre
garamian je passe par exemple
et donc là il y a deux façons de jouer
soit grand rock
soit kb5 c'est pour ça que je t'ai
mentionné qui avait 5 tout à l'heure
je pense reviens OK
à la place d'un 3 l'autre coup marrant
ça je peux te montrer ici c'est 4
le 5 que j'ai 5 ouais
il y a beaucoup de théories donc pour
revenir pourquoi je dis ça tu reviens
trois fois avant après faut des 7
on revient en vrai ici il faut des 7
donc j'ai dit que c'était le bon coup si
tu fais fou d'eux
en fait en théorie et censé être ok pour
les noirs
c'est la nouvelle idée
OK
du coup pour moi c'est hyper bizarre
qu'il a prévu parce que du coup faut
deux c'était pas le bon coup dans
l'autre
ok donc on peut revenir à guéri il
paraît qu'il y a eu des coups
alors
donc là il y a soit A3 soit d'un F5
qui est S6 E4 moi j'avais travaillé
cette position en 2013 je pense quand je
bossais pour Étienne et d'ailleurs il
l'avait joué contre
et il avait été proche de lui coller et
il y avait un livre qui a été sorti par
un joueur un peu inconnu je sais même
pas s'il est émis je suis pas sûr un
Turc
je crois que ça s'appelle il avait créé
un livre et en fait c'est un mec qui
était connu à l'époque pour avoir des
superordinateurs maintenant
OK
quand même si tu connais pas bien
préparé je pense pour les pour les noirs
est-ce que tu veux je regarde si j'avais
à l'époque donc du coup mes analyses ont
des endroits
donc tu vois c'est une position dans
laquelle je serais complètement en âge
si j'avais je devais jouer avec les
Noirs
enfin t'as pas envie de te faire
attaquer tu préfères avoir l'initiative
moi j'aime pas me faire attaquer ça
c'est clair donc du coup les Noirs
c'est pas le seul coup le coup principal
que j'avais c'était aussi dame C8
d'ailleurs ça je me rappelais même pas
toi à la place de
j'avais dame C8 aussi intéressant
c'est ce que j'avais j'ai 6
d'un F4
E5 cavalier H5 et là en exclamation
ce qui est marrant c'est que les parties
dans la base il y a d'autres chiens
cours récemment avec les blancs en 2022
en septembre et il y a un grand maître
qui a gagné contre kayaki en 2021 c'est
la position critique
OK
j'ai encore beaucoup d'analyses
ok moi j'aime bien les blancs j'aime
beaucoup les blancs
[Musique]
et Alpha zéro stock fish c'était quoi
les parties moi j'avais adoré moi ce
match ça m'avait
ça m'avait régalé
j'adore ça
alors
un petit peu obligé tu te laisses
prendre 5 c'est complètement chaud
il avait pas joué dame
G40 parce que je viens de dire
il avait gagné deux fois
sur ça du coup
j'avais mis moins bon mais bon si Dieu a
joué l'autre coup
[Musique]
très curieux de voir ce qui va se passer
la partie je peux la voir ça t'intéresse
vas-y vas-y
il y en a qu'une
il n'y a pas de puent de 6
on va commencer à réfléchir
pris en fait j'ai l'impression ouais
avec
l'ouest et là de la surprise un peu en
jouant la ligne la plus chère parce que
on le connaît un peu plus l'autre entre
guillemets oui complètement
il joue il joue vraiment tu vois
moi je pense que
guéri peut aller essayer de chercher
grâce à un bonjour tu vois
quand même assez logique
c'est-à-dire
prise cavalier prend
puis on prend des 6 x 6
si je mange là tu manges là et c'est que
les avantages
ok c'est chaud en tout cas si je décide
comme ça c'est qu'il connaît la pause
il est obligé de jouer 5 et du coup
c'est cette finale
des fois pour moi
c'est assez logique
[Musique]
ouais c'est intéressant après la
question c'est à quel point
on me demande 5 alors 5 c'est que je
menace pour prendre les 7 et qui est
prendre des sept échec
mais tu penses que gay il est pas prêt
jusqu'à
je pense qu'il se rappelle plus de tes 6
c'est sûr qu'il se rappelle pas
c'était très léger avantage blanc
c'était même pas sûr et le super
ordinateur TCC là tu connais le truc
norvégien
B4 et que les 030 même pas
il veut juste reprendre et te dire
tu attaques des 6 au pire je fais j'ai 5
croisé 7 ou G6 rg7
[Musique]
enfin j'exagère peut-être mais
je vois pas trop
sortir
c'est quoi exactement
[Musique]
ça va être intéressant
donc on va voir cette position donc il a
voilà encore une fois gros boulot de la
team Carson mais pour moi c'était un
petit avantage blanc ce truc mais bon
maintenant avec les super ordi
mais du coup si des six marchent c'est à
dire que c'est peut-être hyper important
pour la théorie
ouais
il est peut-être en train de plier de
toi c'est ça
c'est ouf
c'était censé je connaissais pas du tout
est-ce qu'il y a pas des parties par
correspondance attends je vais regarder
tu es souvent c'est la clé les parties
par correspondances
qui avait gagné en 2009 donc il savait
déjà toi
avec les blancs en 2008 quand il Yannick
Pelletier
c'est pas choquant ça
la finale je parle après
la différence entre une ligne qu'on
avait oublié parce que le score est
plutôt bon et c'est là où je trouve que
la team Carlson est vraiment très forte
c'est pour ressortir des lignes comme ça
parce qu'il faut faut y penser à se dire
attends mais là on va peut-être chercher
peut-être que ça va
je suis en train de regarder mon truc
j'ai un problème là avec
eux qui fait que de bugger comme
mais du coup
[Musique]
l'extension un truc bizarre je le dirai
ouais ça peut être ça c'est un truc de
musique quoi
sinon j'ai Adblock j'ai des trucs comme
ça tu vois normalement c'est pas ça fait
pas trop planter non puis j'ai aussi
j'ai aussi un truc c'est style stylish
c'est un truc qu'on m'avait donné pour
rocher score en fait
du coup normalement c'est pas ça
c'est une vraie question je sais juste
que tout le monde avait joué l'autre tu
sais quoi j'ai laissé tourner mon ordi
puissant il propose donc le truc nouveau
autour des 8 de l'ordi de
ici
avec l'idée cahier des 5 H6
OK
il met 01 25
[Musique]
je sais pas quoi
des stars de classe comme par rapport à
l'esprit en fait ils avaient besoin de
cette extension et du coup je l'ai
depuis toujours en fait donc c'est pas
ça qui me fait bugger
et d'ailleurs tu as jamais été joué mais
c'est deux pourquoi pas en fait qu'à
proposer dans le chat il y a eu trois
parties donc voici
[Musique]
la dame qui a bougé
il y a trois parties
3 et là petit rock ou grand rock bien
sûr
[Musique]
il y a des parties donc là la question
c'est les deux à quel point ils
connaissent
ok c'est cool la partie est quand même
assez cool à ceux
que c'est le du coup pour avec la même
idée parce que
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr
j'aimerais tellement avoir révisé ce
matin ça
quand tu le vois la caméra il a l'air
comme d'essayer de se rappeler
et après
petit tour allez tu t'en vas alors du
coup on a annoncé il y a 20 minutes
et l'idée c'est que je veux prendre en
H4 et si tu me prends j'ai 5 je fais
dames prends
c'est pas la dernière partie du match ou
la VAN dernière
dans les parties je veux sur le site
[Musique]
heureusement j'ai pas accès
toutes les parties qui ont été fait dans
la poste
[Musique]
ils sont pas très gênés par tout ça
sur l'italienne
[Musique]
du coup qui va empêcher la prise
d'espace du coup des blancs avec des 4
MP3
le fait que tu es pas tes besoins de
jouer à 5 tu as perdu un temps quand
même
mais par contre du coup tu as provoqué
le f pro
mais quand tu vois ça tu te dis ça doit
aller pour une heure mais bon c'est pas
encore complètement égal dans le sens
des quatre à l'air plus fort que des 5
je sais pas si c'est clair cette phrase
le fait la menace D4 est plus forte que
c'est la menace des cinq des Noirs
tu as compris quand je l'ai dit je me
suis dit c'est pas très clair
tout le monde me parle d'une nouveauté
sur la lapine dans le tournoi B alors je
vais aller voir quand même
si on me bluff et il a pris en dessert
j'avoue qu'on pourrait se faire un petit
montage Mathieu à chaque fois
[Musique]
dans des pronostics sur la variante
choisie et là regarde on a exactement la
prochaine
vidéo aussi il y a eu d'ailleurs
asperger 5 d'un projet 5 et
Ding on était pas mal non plus quoi
il a joué un H4 assez bizarre c'est vrai
mais qui est pas illogique en fait déjà
l'ouverture noire est un peu bizarre le
B6 c'est pas la ligne principale mais
c'est vrai cache 4 j'ai jamais vu
c'est une nouveauté
ok donc là c'est donc en fait c'est une
Brière
enfin c'est une Espagnole ou mais juste
il a pas eu besoin de jouer des cartes
pour l'instant enfin il a pas fait
comme ça la position avec des cinq
cavaliers
trois fois
c'est une nouveauté pour moi le supplie
la partie dans le tournoi B d'ailleurs
la partie qui a été jouée par
la comment elle s'appelle Eline
[Musique]
c'est quoi son nom déjà
ils sont préparés ces gens-là
ils font un gros tournoi puis elle est
quand même elle est jeune c'est un
espoir dans son pays
donc ça c'est pas trop intéressant pour
l'instant on va être la partie peut être
super intéressante toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier il y a tous les pions c'est
que pour l'instant il s'est rien passé
par contre joue bien ses positions c'est
un petit Magnus dans le style c'est ce
qu'avait dit son entraîneur il vient de
Sokolov et Magnus est le meilleur joueur
du monde de ces Espagnols donc c'est pas
bête de jouer Detroit qu'on parle qui
qui joue des trucs très théoriques
l'autre jour il avait joué l'espagnol
poussé 5 donc d'ailleurs param a changé
cette fois il a joué 7 pas fou c'est ça
et donc H3 faut que j'ai 7 jouets ouais
des fois c'est pas si malin de mettre le
Foussier rapidement ici parce que là les
blancs peuvent commencer à jouer du A4
B4 je sais des fois
oh
Magnus des fois il fait cavaler le 3 tu
sais jamais trop pourquoi je passe un
remarqué aussi des fois ils font Fuger 5
les mecs hachis s'ils repartent ils sont
contents moi j'ai toujours eu du mal à
comprendre ces trucs c'est trop fin
culture j'ai joué très très peu
d'espagnol classique dans ma vie voir
proche de zéro moi aussi mais après je
joue des même genre pas en place s'il y
a une poubelle 5 échecs
comme ça mais par exemple bah moi je
considère que la marge 6 ça peut être un
rubrissement en fait pour pour les noirs
sur longtemps
c'est pour ça que généralement quand je
avant de faire
mon geste enfin
j'aime bien mettre le four en G5 d'abord
mais est-ce que c'est bien enfin c'est
toujours rien compris saut à rognon
alors c'était une position bizarre où on
avait une simplification au centre
et on a eu B2
c'est quoi ça ah mais je crois que j'ai
lu j'ai lu un dérèglement du tournoi qui
disait qu'il voulait que les enfin que
les joueurs qui faisaient mieux en moins
de 30 coups et moins de 3 heures de jeu
vous pouvez
ne plus être invité au tournoi voilà
donc voilà peut-être la proposition il
dit bon est-ce que tu fais nul ou tu
veux que mettre invité l'année prochaine
en fait voilà il trouve que que
[Musique]
ça fait du bien de jouer le parti longue
mais c'est
financièrement c'est un des pires
tournant de l'année pour un il est long
et tu gagnes rien en comparaison très
bien mais
mais bon voilà juste
j'ai lu ça j'ai lu ça et du coup
les organes du fight
et
du coup
bon peut-être que ça il va il va il va
jouer
enfin pour tu vois
aussi
il y a pas de centre blanc
et tu cherches un coup
d'avant
mais du coup c'est la position
[Musique]
qui est un problème sur le pion B et
maintenant
parce que là maintenant du coup tu
regrettes un peu d'avoir jouécate
OK
c'est la créative mind sur le chat que
je connais très très bien c'est bien
venu
donc
pour voir un petit peu sa tête ce qui
veut faire un nulle ou pas ah non il
avait il allait
réfléchi fortement et pas la bonne
caméra vous le montrez un saut est là
non je viens de la changer là
il y a quelques secondes
je tente pour avoir une heure et je joue
B2 non mais bon après ok alors en vrai
tu peux pas blâmer un joueur avec les
Noirs
maintenant je l'invite plus jamais il a
trop peur de jouer c'est inintéressant
au moins guiric est assez peur quand il
joue il se force à jouer actif
après guérir pour le coup là c'est le
genre local
il a quoi en ce moment il a eu une bonne
période il fait deux trois bons tournois
sur Internet on sait pas comment
mais
[Musique]
il est un peu mou il a un peu mou
RA merci sa maman à chaque partie ça
allez
[Musique]
on va aller voir un petit peu à l'Asie
du coup
c'est le Lord ouais non mais le Lord
aussi mais il y avait une histoire comme
quoi c'était il y a hyper longtemps
Mathieu tu vas connaître l'anecdote
c'était un championnat des États-Unis je
crois il est contre akoviar un truc
comme ça et en fait il avait perdu la
partie parce qu'il avait écrit sur sa
feuille et en fait il avait écrit des
trucs du style
genre
écrivait genre reste concentré
en anglais il lui disait genre vérifie
plusieurs fois avant de jouer plein de
petits conseils comme ça qui s'étaient
écrit sur ça sur sa feuille
et
une fois deux fois l'arbitre qui dit bon
arrête de le faire parce que t'as pas le
droit de faire ça quoi il y a pas de
marquer des trucs comme ça sur ta
feuille et troisième fois
ciao quoi et
il avait perdu la partie quoi c'était
ouf quoi
je sais pas à quel point ça c'est
vraiment mieux
ouais
j'ai aucune idée est-ce que demain
du cavalier tu as plus de mal à je sais
que s'il prend la dame qui avait lieu 5
mon bête un peu
la casse C4 peut-être c'est un peu de
plus de malade de C4 c'est mon cavalier
là
est-ce que ça vaut le coup pour toi
d'avoir échangé plus de pièces non plus
c'est une vraie question j'aurais
tendance à dire non par exemple je
prends tout et x 3
il est où
il a joué d'un projet
donc
préparer un rapport je pense
parce qu'il réfléchit beaucoup et on
voit
aussi ça t'imagines
mais en fait c'est ça n'existe pas
ok il y a une en décembre il y en a une
c'est chaud pour les blancs je peux pas
ok quoi je peux jamais invoquer la vraie
nouveauté dans la base il y a une partie
en 2009 que j'avais pas l'autre jour
d'ailleurs c'est drôle et je vais
regarder dans ma base enfin dans ma base
dans ma prépa
je sais pas si j'avais rajouté mes
parties contre un Bolton dans ma base
donc j'avais F3 dame C5 j'avais pas
mais l'ordi respecte pas trop
quand même
mais tu fais quoi en fait
mais du coup
j'ai envie de manger
[Musique]
quand tu as enlevé l'extension
attends je viens là ah c'est pour ça
qu'il est monté qu'il a tenté d'accord
j'ai un tour G8 et là je me fais je me
fais avoir mais moi aussi j'ai dame là
derrière
mais je parlerai des cinq voilà ça pue
ça pue ça pue déjà c'est Magnus
réfléchit et normalement c'est censé là
être là où il a la nouvelle idée tour
des 8 jamais joué ou à 6 plutôt que le
Kai B4 joue en pratique
c'est un autre streamer il a eu le même
problème que moi bah merci routes donc
ça vient peut-être de checker en fait
[Musique]
une astuce
de
là on est rentré
2014 pour Macron
j'hallucine ah oui c'est quel cinq
nouveautés l'autre coup c'était tourner
ça a été joué depuis
par en 200300 verres hargen
[Rires]
il y a eu
on va remettre
caméra
à la fin
ouais mais du coup il y avait le 5 c'est
obligatoire non c'est toujours quoi
[Musique]
et son idée c'est comme ça il s'est pas
fait clouer et
[Musique]
bien
tout de suite je sais pas il est en tête
d'ailleurs tu peux retarder ça mais
genre il a cette idée d'avoir la case
des quatre
manœuvre malin pour venir en fait en
deux quatre c'est ça
direct ouais mais du coup aussi pourquoi
tu fais pas genre HS enfin un coup
en fait l'idée ça c'est important on
veut jouer G6
bah tu fais que par exemple
trop bien
[Musique]
c'est peut-être que cette vieille ligne
va maintenant que les ordinateurs
en fait tu savais tout quoi depuis le
début tu l'as toujours
vraiment à fond
ou là
j'ai perdu j'ai passé plusieurs jours
cavalier E4 on nous propose il y a pas
qui fourchettes j'ai la fourchette tu
vois
non la tour est en D1 a été après
tourner mais
du coup tu as plus
F4 par exemple
et on va voir cette manœuvre qui a
essayé de cahier des cadres je pense
c'est vraiment un championnat de Norvège
ou quoi
non
je pense que
parce que quand il a joué cavalent le
petit regard à Gardin je pense que gris
connais en fait il a passé une
demi-heure pour mon bien se rappeler des
lignes tout ça mais je pense que ouais
il a dû piquer les analyses mais
alors tu nous as caché que tu es aussi
secondaire
ok tu veux la ligne ou pas
[Musique]
OK
le seul coup mais c'est le coup je pars
correspond
poussez vite et voilà et dans mon
fichier à l'époque j'avais
naïvement cavalier E5 mais pas
correspondance le mec a joué
un
et 5 roses
quand même
si je prends
ouais bon du coup tu seras pas surpris
de savoir que c'est les meilleurs coups
c'est un truc comme ça fu F4
recette
autour des 8
tours
j'avais pas mais ça a été joué par
correspondance
OK
voilà vous savez tout donc c'est
généralement les parties vraiment de
référence de haut niveau
et donc c'est un peu un échec un peu
différent de ce que nous on connaît en
fait
nous voilà
tes fichiers moi le premier truc je
regarde si les parties qui
correspondance ou partie en longue
et après il faut pas oublier c'est pas
parce que l'ordi égale que ça va faire
nul si vous voyez une position égale
d'après l'ordi mais genre il y a genre 3
victoires une nulle c'est à dire qu'elle
est peut-être très dur à jouer en
pratique
il faut pas non plus être complètement
déprimé que leur
oui après il y a clairement la
pratique c'est hyper important en fait
ça c'est c'est clair et c'est la fameuse
nouveauté de guérir de jour la tour 2
l'ordi mais 0,20 pour les noirs on s'en
fout il a un plan il sait ce qu'il doit
faire il connaît les thèmes l'autre
connaît pas l'autre se trompe il lui
fait un prix
maintenant le haut niveau c'est ça c'est
pas trop un coup qui donne l'avantage il
y a pas l'avantage tout le monde a le
voit la première ligne de l'ordi donc
l'idée c'est genre chercher genre le
troisième quatrième coup de l'ordi et le
pousser à fond
oui exactement
spolangeki il y a aussi l'effet inverse
avec des fois tu sais que tu es mieux
mais c'est introuvable tu sais que la
position est égale ça m'a fait penser ça
j'en parle à chaque fois la partie Ding
carwana au Candida le premier où il
avait joué une slave de ouf super
nouveauté bah savent que godding avait
afficher une heure et demie il y avait
trouvé pas la meilleure ligne mais un
truc jouable et ben après quand il
fallait jouer tout seul bah il avait
perdu assez facilement et digne avait
fait une partie fantastique
c'est le défaut ouais c'est le tableau
est mieux si tu dois trouver six coups
pour notre animation à la suite tu peux
même perdre tes prépas où tu es mieux ça
ça m'est arrivé
c'est un grand classique
ce petit
tourbillon à F7 alors il sait pas c'est
quoi on avait eu
pour moi
échanger les pièces
des 4 cavaliers 7
OK et pour moi les blancs sont un peu
mieux mais
tu as vraiment des chances de gains ici
j'ai du mal à y croire
[Musique]
pourquoi un peu muse un peu plus
d'espace en tout simplement
la colonne E et rentrer
je vais être moins bien non tu prends
tout
est-ce que je peux toucher
[Musique]
pour faire 5
je pousse ici
voilà moi je ferme le statu quo c'est
peut-être égal
mais bon je suis clairement moi
sort de l'eau et chaque
sauce ça joue il y a pas eu la nul
il y a eu d'un point à trois directement
et ton FDA
mérite d'être puni
non mais en fait bon il risque de faire
nul tous les deux en fait mais mais
l'idée c'est que
l'idée c'est que du coup ils doivent
jouer en fait
et Abdou ce qui me fait rire c'est que
leur dites les blancs sont vraiment
mieux maintenant il a rien fait
en fait visiblement le fou sur G7 c'est
le gros manque de culture en parrain il
bosse beaucoup mais que des ordis il
connaît pas les classiques visiblement
c'est pas un bon plan ça quand le mec
fait rien la vraie c'est que tu remets
le fond G7 pour que je te préparé qu'on
ne décatte mais le mec l'a pas fait
c'est un peu perturbant
ouais c'est clair
où peut-on trouver des bases de partie
de championnat d'ordinateur c'est pas
facile
par exemple tcec le site la plupart du
temps je commande des parties qui
viennent de ce site c'est un site où il
y a un tournoi ils ont une chaîne twitch
d'ailleurs
il y a toujours 150 personnes qui
regardent des parties
tu peux aller dans archives et
télécharger il y avait entamé la 24e
saison
sinon il y en a d'autres il y a
eu le halmage alpha zéro
stock fish il y a un sentiercom il y a
un tournoi d'ordi qui a lieu tous les
jours là tu pourrais suivre des parties
si tu veux mais le problème c'est que
c'est dur
à télécharger
je pense que je sais qui tu es
vu ton pseudo donc si c'est bien toi qui
je pense et ben salut à toi j'espère que
tu vas bien
Annie soit
et
donc les parties ordinateurs c'est pas
les parties qui pourraient amateurs sont
les plus intéressants tu vois parce
qu'on ne comprend en fait rien quoi je
pense que pour vraiment
ouais en fait il faut réussir tu vois à
bien déchiffrer tout ça parce que
c'est compliqué quoi tu vois en fait ils
sont tellement profonds et puissants en
fait juste une fois j'ai fait le master
j'avais préparé j'ai mis trois ou quatre
heures à préparer une masterclass d'une
heure et demie sur des parties d'ordi
il faut que tu fasses un gros boulot de
toi te compréhension tout ça de nuances
de enfin c'est ouf un dessin qui a été
joué du coup je sais pas Rama mais je
crois que c'est pas bon
OK
me demande pas pourquoi
si tu vas me demander
à quatre des quatre
moi je suis plutôt maximaliste comme toi
donc je pense que tous les deux on
regarderait on regarderait des cartes en
premier non
plus des quatre ou mais bon des cas toi
c'est pas sûr que ça marche ici parce
que la différence c'est quand son dessin
quand je fais des quatre
si tu prends E4 je fais que
en fait
[Musique]
tu peux pas reprendre tu dois prendre en
D4
et là où j'ai 5 peut-être
attention
[Musique]
mais
ça donne pas forcément
mais je peux avoir un petit isolé
ouais mais c'est un téléphone
on va imaginer un coup H6 non bah je
sais pas
mais un petit coup qui sert vraiment à
rien des cinq gagne une pièce qu'elle va
les prendre je suis cloué bien sûr d'en
prendre FC c'est surtout quand
déviation de tout à l'heure je peux même
manger des cinq
donc ok moi j'aime bien
alors attends juste ici en savoir plus
excuse-moi mais j'ai envie d'en savoir
plus non je comprends rien je vais
revenir
parce que quelqu'un peut voilà il
faudrait que tu envoies à quelqu'un du
chat le code erreur qui regarde pendant
que tu commentes ok donc Descartes
qui prend un 4 si tu es obligé de faire
cavalier prend un quatre
ça me paraît une énorme menace
pour défendre
ça on a envie d'éviter ça avec les Noirs
je pense
mais du coup sur des quatre tu dois si
tu me prends des cartes
[Musique]
OK et du coup alors si il prend la
un truc pour les noirs
d'être cool
et un coup comme vous F5 pour rester
toutes les changer
[Musique]
tu vas prendre ces deux tu as raison on
revient je fais une bêtise je reviens je
fais fouger 5
ça m'a l'air d'être une poubelle alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a vu
on te dit d'utiliser Firefox
[Musique]
de navigateur c'est
je peux le faire c'est pas un problème
mais juste si on fait une pause on peut
essayer après
je peux l'essayer mais
le problème apparemment vient de chez
com de toute façon
qui a eu le même problème il était sur
donc tu as là j'ai tous les sites j'ai
mis j'ai
tout mes trucs à côté toutes mes
fenêtres j'ai pas de problème c'est que
sur
le problème vient de là
le pédiatre est venu me voir il m'a dit
ce matin j'ai vu cornet seul faire la
vidéo j'ai compris que vous étiez là
c'est énorme
je suis content
va pas en fait c'est ce qu'est
normalement quand on fait ça le cavalier
est en F1 pour pouvoir sur des 4 pouvoir
prendre les quatre et là le cavalier est
déjà en G3 pour contrôler le
la case E4
je suis d'accord
mais
en fait je crois juste que dessin que
c'est juste pas l'idée je suis désolé je
suis un peu perfectionné je peux le
regarder
depuis le début
ça veut déjà été joué par des grands
maîtres ok pas un deux
et tous les coups eux prend des décatés
à 4 donner plus un pour les blancs
juste tout d'un coup ça passe ce bloc
c'est la partie de son pas terminée du
tout
ouais bon je vais voir de toute façon
on arrive aussi c'est oui comment tu
peux croire que c'est un mug une erreur
mais peut-être que c'est chrome avec
mais ok bon
ok j'ai regardé ça peut te cagoule du
coup
c'est très proche de ce qu'on a dit puis
on prend un 4
[Musique]
donc c'est ce que j'étais tout franc
puis on prend prise D1 pour prendre 5 F3
mon frère F3 d'ailleurs c'est à débattre
cavalier à 5 F4
et voilà j'en étais là après j'ai arrêté
de regarder
à quel point c'est
à quel point tu fais mal aux mec c'est
la question
voilà oui
F2 mon roi il enlève de quoi il empêche
la tour de rentrer en fait il y a ce
pion en G6 aussi il est quasiment faible
il y a aussi même du prix c'est du prix
d'ambiance
de profiter que la tour soit pas
défendue en A8 pour jouer à 4 ouvrir
ton idée
genre en mode contrôle domination
autour des deux la jauge peut-être
est-ce que est-ce que un coup comme B4
c'est vraiment une un coup débile de
cavalerie il a plus de 15 en fait
[Musique]
d'un côté de l'autre donc pour gagner la
colonne et puis un problème sur R6 qui
peut avoir lieu et puis aussi celui-là
il y a des maths du couloir ça a l'air
très dur en pratiquant cette pause
franchement
[Musique]
tiens j'ai du fouger 5 du coup H6 des
matchs du couloir du Tour des 7
c'est un cauchemar franchement en plus
Abdou et bon c'est parti c'est là
l'avantage il va pas le lâcher quoi j'ai
même mes 4 ans
j'avais pas pensé en fait
mais
quelque chose donc B4 pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est peut-être la mauvaise nouvelle en
fait ça marchera
tu fais et c'est pas ça que tu en as
vraiment bien
ok donc on va faire un petit tour des
stades un résumé on en est où Carlsen
alors attends
c'est la partie qu'on a suivi donc là
c'était cavalier C4 D7 avec le four en
C8 tu avais dit qu'il avait les C4 il me
semble si j'ai pas de bêtises c'était
jusque-là
je me rappelle plus ouais c'était ok
c'est encore dans la prépa un truc
chelou comme ça je crois que ça ça
ça
non
ok donc alors
les deux se rappellent plus trop donc ça
peut être intéressant parce qu'on est
humain
rapporte
[Musique]
il y a eu du coup
tu es pas loin de te prendre que prendre
des cartes aussi sous il veut jouer dans
F5 quoi ça je suis d'accord avec toi
donc
ça marche pas donc comment on fait
on me demande si tocrace par rapport à
Stargate et la réponse est oui
improbable il avait déjà dit sur le
stream l'autre jour
je sais pas si lui il l'a vu sinon
il le sait
c'est très fort
je dis bravo
veut dire contre le Diora en Go à Old
évidemment
[Rires]
3 B8 a pour empêcher d'échanger d'âme
mais le problème c'est que ça
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux jouer donc
tu peux non
je viens de voir une idée marrante c'est
un calculer je pensais à ça
ça va
[Musique]
oui mais c'était les j'ai regardé toutes
les séries moi tous les dérivés mais
c'était dans le premier c'est rien
oui je suis pas si jeune
je pensais à ça peut-être que je suis
complètement parce que maintenant en
fait bon ordinateur
effectivement OK
du coup dame
C25 il y a tout en l'air mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est je m'en sors bien
tout réussissent qui attaque là et là
donc là
tu as peut-être
c'est tombé ici en fait je menace rien
donc et B4 pas non plus ok là les Noirs
tu en as pour au moins 20 minutes
ok mais en tout cas positionne moi
j'aime bien les Noirs parce qu'en
pratique il faut que les Blancs
réussissent à l'abri un cavalier 6
intéressant ou qui a à la fois empêche
d'AMF 5 et en plus
prépare pour ces 6 avec
toi je veux rentrer dans ta position je
prends le contrôle de la colonne est
ouverte
les
personnages non je suis pas d'accord
c'est ça les goals sont nos avec le lot
et je t'ai perdu là non mais moi je la
regardais la série mais c'était il y a
trop longtemps j'ai je suis un peu
de rien
et du coup oui parce que ça marchait pas
et donc il ajoute ton cou il se donne du
Tour C6 un jour et surtout il compte il
veut jouer à H4
on n'a pas petit Grand Roc et on n'a pas
petit rock d'ailleurs
[Musique]
il faut voir si je peux vraiment
pour essayer un jour de rentrer par là
si jamais mais bon je peux que la tourne
c'est pas très malin malheureusement
c'est possible et H4 et pas grand chose
développement
[Musique]
comment on fait pour garder les dames
sur Dumbledore
moi je pense à ça pour pouvoir jouer à
H4 parce que je me dis que si tu bouffes
j'aimerais pouvoir en fait pas sec
madame mais bon peut-être que c'est
débile
en plus je bloquer la tour donc c'était
pas forcément le plus malin mais dame de
chat pourquoi
on a perdu la colonnage
[Musique]
de jouer
peut-être qu'il a rien vu ça c'est
ce qu'on a loupé mais peut-être rien
alors peut-être qu'il veut faire tourner
à la suite
H4 H3 et ça va faire nul
puis on prend une prise
mais bon je bouge pas non plus mais
peut-être que je peux me faire tourner
c'était québeccat
je comprends pas sa ligne
ah oh vas-y montre ça absurde
au lieu donc là il met 0-0 ça va faire
nul
ouais
[Musique]
tu peux jouer H4
et si d'un premier cas de tomber si
direct c'est encore plus fort parce que
faut deux mine de rien ça a aidé les
blancs dans ce qu'ils étaient un peu
sous pression ça a aidé les blancs à
simplifier
donc en fait ici une grand rock il
préférait les noirs
mais généralement c'est du calcul un peu
voilà ton truc c'est pas très bien joué
d'ailleurs échec échec est un procédé
[Musique]
c'est un peu
mais ok bon c'est clair que là les noirs
[Musique]
on joue les coups
qui récite la partie de la partie
2016 par correspondance ok à 26 juillet
j'imagine
de cette recette
en tout cas les deux joueurs a priori
sont encore vivants
donc les deux c'est sûr qu'ils l'ont
dans leur fichier mais les deux se
rappellent pas bien
mais comme ils ont des mémoires de ouf
ils vont arriver à retrouver je pense
que le pouce
il est
certaines bien sûr
des fois maintenant c'est quelques mois
mais avant c'était un coup par semaine
par exemple fou c'est 8 à venir
exactement
[Musique]
c'est possible que qu'on ait une
répétition avec F4 aussi
j'ai envie de parier sur ça
et est-ce qu'il risque vraiment avec
l'autre pas sur non plus
long
du coup il s'est passé
un changement structure aussi dans la
position Mathieu je sais pas si c'est
intéressant
je mets tout le monde sur la 4e
[Musique]
on a vu la ligne tout à l'heure c'est
l'avantage blanc on menace fouger 5 et
avoir un clouage mortel c'est très très
chiant
du coup tu avais dit ça ça
on donne le foot casse noir pardon il y
avait un intermédiaire
de le jouer mais très dur à jouer
c'est ça qu'on a des prises là tu avais
proposé à 4 qui était malin et à Cécile
B4
et la jauge nous a pas contredit donc on
est pas encore
c'est quand même ultra déplaisant
conjo qui avait aussi cet Orsay c'est
très chiant
normalement ça doit pas tenir ok parram
il a écrit avec les Noirs mais bon des
trois très très bons choix de ça tourne
regarde la surprise
deux heures de jeu ils ont dépasser 30
coups
[Musique]
c'était prévisible en fait aussi tu vois
la vitesse de jeu en fait c'est ça ils
ont même avant la partie ça va être déjà
qu'ils allaient faire nul
pourquoi
il y a toujours un peu
là il y avait E2 en prise et si tu
prends ton reprend si tu fais faut
prendre il y a autour des 8 et
je vais faire cette vidéo demain
perso
un petit tour de magie
plus jamais sur cette partie
et du coup il a joué donc la partie de
la pris en B3 on savait pas si c'est 4
était une idée ouais il a pris de la
dame en fait du coup
mais là on ne met pas trop après
tous les cas on n'aimait pas trop un B6
stratégiquement ça me rappelle beaucoup
la partie d'hier
de Magnus
C4 ça rend le fou bon ou tu montes en
fait
il veut échanger des pièces les Noirs
jouent solides qui F3 tours C7 admettons
l'améliore dans mes 4
tu peux jouer avec
je foi 6
j'ai pas
géométrique
moi les noirs pour moi sont confortables
ici il a pas réussi
pas très bien dans ce tournoi désolé de
me répéter
donc ça ça là ça va durer les noirs
peuvent peut-être même la pression ils
ont 15000 d'avance à pendule rapporte
kerwana on pense que les ça va faire nul
qui est cuite a bien joué pourquoi il a
récupéré la colonache il change dans
ça c'est logique
bien joué ça pour mettre le client ici
préfère toujours les Noirs ils ont 50
minutes mais bon nul ça va normalement
ça devrait
la gueule pour l'instant
et si tu vois en F5 la tour qui passe en
H1 et puis je peux passer derrière un
peu
arrêtez avec ce mot blender c'est juste
c'est trop compliqué il a joué un coup
c'est pas le meilleur c'est tout blanc
c'est quand on oublie un truc dans une
ligne c'est pas pareil
mais que ça ça rognan
et du coup là on avait dit que le coup
c'était royal
et du coup il ajoute à Valérie c'est
un cahier des quatre
tours
[Musique]
mais c'est pas un blender après ça peut
être erreur
en quoi c'est mal joué
[Musique]
après si tu veux je peux aller voir le
pourquoi mais je sais pas ok on va
essayer de comprendre sans avant de
regarder l'ordi
donc
[Musique]
en fait
une impressionnant mais c'est peut-être
une erreur mais une erreur et un blender
c'est pas pareil
même
si je peux manger
ok donc il faut essayer
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas un B3 qui a un
coup qu'on avait jamais eu parce qu'il
appartenait pas la position mais là il y
a qu'à aider si c'est encore
B3 du coup
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas trop ton
idée comme ça comme ça OK
ok on revient est-ce que B4 est un coup
on prend les 7
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à faire marcher le BC non
B4 vas-y j'ai une idée non ça peut pas
marcher ça
peut-être un problème non BC qui arrive
x 3 tour B8
ça c'est la gueule d'un truc fort
on va dire du coup je crois je crois que
tu reconnaisselle était pas le coup
il faut que
tu
penses mais bon ce que tu as
un KF3 je pense je prends je prends C5
était un gros problème j'ai un problème
non mais ok
ça dépend ce que tu fais d'ailleurs le
foot des cinq raisons
tu as tout compris
est-ce que c'est une bonne journée bah
oui ça va ça va il y a du mal notre
petite nul ouais c'est B4 les gens
disent mais hyper compliqué
j'ai galéré j'ai un peu trouvé
en tout cas
ta barre moi j'ai jamais analysé avec la
barre c'est un supportable ce compte
toujours BK la barbe baisse un peu
mais j'ai compris que c'était le coup en
fait quand même parce que la colonne B
si tu veux savoir
voilà c'est juste l'initiative paire de
fou x 3 x F4
tout qui rentre
c'est fort
parce que tu vois franchement
carcène qui sort de la partie de
référence et qui d'ailleurs du coup ben
ça
et du coup guéri tilte un peu parce
qu'il se dit que
ça va pas quoi tu vois il se souvenait
plus loin qu'un scène et du coup dirige
pense qu'il est un peu dans le sens il
se dit que c'était pas le coup quoi tu
vois et maintenant Guiri qui est
et qui se plainte
dure la vie
il y en a un qui bosse
ok donc guéri peut mettre la pression
mais bon c'est le genre de position il
faut être un peu précis
est-ce qu'on va voir
ce Google je crois qu'on a oublié la
partie non
oubliez on a un petit peu oublié
avec Kevin on avait on avait oublié une
fois entièrement
pour répondre à la dernière question
pourquoi B4 pas B3 en fait B4 c'est pour
ouvrir la position prendre en C5 et
surtout activer la tombée en fait on va
perdre le pion des 6 le pion des têtes
par exemple
mais c'est juste un peu
qui va le voir
il va je t'en prie F6 on prend B7 et tu
as pas de gains
je te prends la part de fou quand même
non je suis d'accord je te colle elle
est morte
du coup le fond en deux est pas
forcément bien placé
thématique aussi donc la E5 est très
possible mais ça affaiblirait mais bon
ça serait quand même pas
c'est un vrai coup d'ailleurs au passage
est-ce que fossette était pas un coup
avec l'idée si tu manges des six je te
mange en fait ok je pense que tu peux
pas jouer ça parce que
DCI
on me demande est-ce que on pense qui
c'est qui a quelque chose non parce que
guéri je pense pas qu'il se rappelle
qu'elle était la ligne principale encore
ils sont déjà au 20e coups ils ont pas
il a pas préparé ça ce matin c'est sûr
parce que l'autre joue jamais des
westerns
donc là il ajoute Damas 5 et logique
mais qui était pas forcément faut
toujours regarder des dessins qui est le
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
s'échange contre le cavalier
tout à l'heure tu parlais d'une idée qui
avait eu alors je sais plus laquelle
c'était mais faut revenir au début c'est
chiant mais il y avait tout à l'heure
juste pour pour caricaturer en fait
imaginons si on joue E5 en fait il y a
plein de fois des idées où tu joues
quand tu joues F4 hein
tu repars en G5 et après tu prends la
case des 5 quoi on va imaginer un truc
juste pour pour dire en fait surtout F4
souvent on joue ici un F4 E5 fougères 5
pour en fait éliminer le cavalier avec
le fou pour en venir un super cavalier
sur la case des 5 en fait c'était Matic
et le concept H6 d'abord pour empêcher
le feuilleton qui est après seulement on
fera le 5 pour garder le cavalier parce
que les Blancs pouvaient changer le fou
et je pour F4 et ça lui faisait peur
donc il ajoute Damas ok
il a joué du coup Robin
la protection
[Musique]
ok
j'ai l'impression que les noirs sont ok
se joue à pas grand chose c'est position
mais quel est son idée avec Orange et du
mal à bon moi il a plus envie de jouer
G4 non
à moins qu'il va y faire caille des cinq
Monny croit pas trop ici avec ton fond
de t'as l'air un peu bête
du coup
[Musique]
en fait j'ai 5 tu retournes avec ton
four en D2 ou c'est un il a l'air et
après la prise du pion en 4 va être un
peu dangereuse
et si tu fais petit
à cause de de fromage si un courage et
le pion je jette en l'air juste sur
récente pourquoi est-ce que
pourquoi est-ce que du coup le pion il
est pas un prix c'est qu'il a foulée
[Musique]
on n'est pas trop content d'avoir du
spion surtout qu'on a un problème
j'ai envie de jouer mais des fois si
t'as pas le choix allez ce qui me laisse
vraiment dans le projet c'est en fait du
coup faut se poser la question à
l'envers
un petit peu
pardon
ah non c'est juste que là elle est
pourrie on voit on voit rien
mais malheureusement
on revient dans un instant à tout de
suite
attendez je vais vous mettre la bonne
cam
mais celle-là
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour je me suis
trompé de Cam encore une fois trompé de
cam et on va retrouver la bonne voilà on
est bon
pendant qu'on est parti il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de son passé on a déjà
eu le B4 ou D5 elle dit qu'on a
mentionné tout à l'heure avec Mathieu
gagnant ça devait pas être la bonne
défense pour la noire du coup je vais
aller voir l'évaluation plus 4 donc
c'est complètement gagnant on attaque le
cavalier on veut jouer BPR français X à
3 comme cavalier pas c'est complètement
fini tôt donc on va voir s'il va finir
mais ça pourrait être une belle vidéo
demain matin
et pendant ce temps là on a eu aussi une
nulle qui était produite parce que je
suis tombé sur une petite info ils ont
fait nul voilà voilà donc voilà
rapidement ce qui s'est passé on s'est
arrêté à
4 comment être un peu mieux presque
échange et en fait maintenant le
problème c'est que les la tour peut
rentrer en H1
bien sûr que c'est pas sur mais
objectivement c'est ça doit gagner F3
tournage 4 et là il va y avoir une
petite erreur de la part des Noirs c'est
là tac tac tac gfdf et en fait ici il y
aura une combinette
il a fait quoi il a fait tourner trois
tu as vu
et si tu me fais trois là tu as fait de
là je pensais que
j'ai pas vu leur dire mais
le marché et si tu fais BK
j'ai envie de te dire plein de coups de
tente j'ai B5
donc en fait il pouvait gagner un pion
il s'est dit il a fini à partir avec
1h22 il s'est dit bon je fais nul en
fait c'est bizarre il a pas cherché ça
jamais Magnus ça lui arrive
je prends nul quand il est un peu mieux
c'est clair ça c'est une énorme erreur à
ce niveau là c'est ouf
final si il fait tourbé un
pourquoi c'est moins grave il
y a trois peut-être
B2
à 4
h
en fait il a juste pensé que ça allait
faire nul dans tous les cas il s'est pas
pris la tête après s'il avait les blancs
de tête que le fait d'avoir les blancs
il aurait essayé de la jouer un peu plus
très bien et il s'est pas pris la tête
quoi ouais ok bon du coup nul on
l'enlève on va faire un petit tour donc
G5
mais juste tu as un petit problème de
roi après on fout des deux pour avoir la
petite
découverte
faudra toujours se méfier de quel point
évidemment tu as raison donc là pour
l'instant c'est pas possible mais ici on
s'attend peut-être à un
[Musique]
et là c'est l'heure d'essayer d'ouvrir
la position avec les Blancs ok les
Blancs ont l'air quand même mieux
ok moi j'aime bien les positions
blanches généralement j'aime bien
attaquer donc c'est clair que ça tu as
un petit coup de étroit ou un petit F3
H4
tu peux jouer plus actif même fous ces
quatre ici il y a du sens où trois fous
des quatre aussi
on se place et puis on pleure
dans ces positions
c'est pas bien donc on va on va on va on
va on va y venir on va voir
décevant dans l'ouverture pour faire le
petit tour de raison après la pause
il y a eu la joie
les fous
il avait plutôt cavaler ses 6 et qui
avait le 7 donc
il veut mettre F5 et D6 probablement
c'est peut-être bien joué mais juste
j'aurais changé les fous ouais ça parait
ok bon bizarre parti bizarre
en gros danger donc il y avait eu des
cartes de cavaliers 4 il a mangé ici
pourquoi tu n'es pas parti pourquoi
la question c'est que toutes les
variantes
la jauge je pense que tu gagnes en bas
juste là
et donc en fait il a mal calculé puis on
prenait qu'à c'était plus deux c'était
fini tôt on peut le remontrer vas-y
remonte puis on prend des quatre il y
avait un truc joli et
du coup il y a une vraie menace donc il
peut pas faire ce qu'il veut il peut pas
jouer fou dessin d'ailleurs ça permet
une pièce aussi donc il doit jeté B4
mais après full B3 c'est la partie sauf
que tu as un pion
le malaise
la partie sauf que tu as une pièce et
l'idée c'est qu'après faut prendre un
prank tu reprends un cas ne marche pas
bien parce qu'il y a
bah ça prend et un peu ta bécane qui
traîne
donc en fait c'était gagnant et à la
place il a joué B3 donc on a pas vu la
suite de la partie
et je voulais trop la faire h6 il y a eu
un enchaînement ok ils ont échangé
ouais mais ouais il s'est dit cette
position doit être mieux mais il faut
prendre un S6 sans doute qu'il peut
faire des Français 3 et c'est juste des
échanges et si tu prends F6 tu prends
des cartes c'est égal ok donc il va s'en
sortir par rame
tu veux pas rechercher l'erreur le nom
de l'erreur non
un message à
toi
demain il y a pas de repos
demain ce genre de repos
oui c'est pour ça contacter un bug et
que tu commandes sur leur site payé par
eux ça se fait
ok donc ça on a vu Ding pragna il y
avait pas grand chose c'était pas funky
à la structure
[Musique]
c'est le truc c'est que l'autre est plus
fort et va lui mettre la pression
c'est ça
ok bon on va revenir du coup à Magnus
un tiers de ses cheveux à la cam ouais
non malheureusement vous savez que j'ai
des problèmes de câble
[Musique]
j'ai un tiers ou voire un quart des
termes qu'on m'a donné qui marche
donc j'ai pas mieux sur Magnus message
ben moi je crois que j'ai les mêmes sauf
que chez moi ça marche pas
mais là je fais que de refresh j'en ai
j'ai 17 caméras
attends après je vais je vais essayer
d'autres si tu veux
je suis arrêté à 13 je vais essayer un
truc
je pense à ce fait de leur demander à la
journée de repos
attends je vais rajouter les trucs à la
main le temps qui passe Magnus il a
compris qu'il y avait un problème qu'il
a dû se tromper quelque part
est-ce que tu penses qu'il va engueuler
ces entraîneurs de son choix de l'Ouest
indienne
s'il est pas content de la prépa
peut-être après est-ce que
le nom de la sbox fatale memoré et que
c'est dead
merci beaucoup écoute je vais me le
garder
et puis je vais réussirai quand même je
pourrais être sûr
attends mais si je t'aurais dit Mathieu
ça vous avez pas le droit pendant
quelques secondes normalement
vous inquiétez pas Mathieu reviens
il faut que je passe un truc sur mon
deuxième écran
enregistrer voilà la nature revient
c'est bon
et
du coup voilà attends je suis en train
d'essayer de mettre d'autres caméras en
plus
j'en ai plus en fait dans la source mais
d'autres qui marchent pas de base donc
j'avais jamais essayé
j'essaie de les rajouter au fur et à
mesure
tac
[Musique]
puis on va faire un point
mais je crois que
ma caméra sont pas marcher pourquoi il
parlera dans le chat ça me paraît bien
[Musique]
quasiment plus
gagner la Coupe du monde après
avoir arrêté pendant longtemps
du coup j'ai rajouté des caméras est-ce
que ça marche
toujours pas
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ça marche
pas
alors pourquoi il se répertant on va
répondre on est il a une cavalière en
prise quand il part les blancs vont
prononcer 5 mettre leurs fausses sur la
3 et rentrer sur la colonne B
et le cavalier vampire il y a plein de
me brûler avec le thé
si vous la couleur de loin je me suis
dit peut-être que c'est une petite
tendresse
[Rires]
le mercredi
qui est à Bordeaux on a
reparti donc là j'ai prévu de faire
calme
pendant un petit moment
ouais donc il est mal et bon mais on
voit pas mais il a pas l'air heureux
ça me rend fou franchement ça me désole
[Musique]
parce qu'on a perdu les photos là voilà
un truc tactiquement dans une partie tu
vois
il a raté un truc
qu'on a pas vu
le coup pour les noirs et on en trouvait
pas trop et là il a jugé 5 donc on a
arrêté de réfléchir et à la place de G5
il a raté
moi j'ai juste pas considéré le coup en
fait c'est logique si tu prends un G7
j'ai ton G8 comme je garde mon cavalier
F6 et après damage 6 peut faire foutran
G2 ok c'est chaud mais au moins
et j'attends Jessica arrive et si tu
fais quel point un CAP en fait c'est ça
marche pas bien pour les blancs
et tu attaque la dame et dame prend
j'essaie c'est les Noirs gagnent
c'est
tous les deux loupé puis on prend
il t'a répondu il faut que tu vides ton
cash ah ouais même ça c'est hyper facile
à faire 2
tu as plus de mémoire sur ton
dans une langue qui n'est pas la mienne
je comprends pas comment je vis mon cash
pour Chrome
ou alors tu option vider le cache ça
s'appelle ouais c'est ça
c'est une option je peux avoir sur
Chrome
non mais j'ai trouvé
efface et tu vas
[Musique]
réinitialiser
restaurer le paramètre par défaut c'est
pas ça nettoyer l'ordinateur
pas ça
système
image efficience c'est ça un mec qui
vient de se faire la
en haut à droite tu cliques sur plus
plus
cliquez sur
d'effacer tout l'historique aussi non
la veste de
ouais mais bon c'est rend fou j'ai pas
mieux
parram je cherche justement les
paramètres mais je crois qu'il est pas
maître par
comment je fais là
chrome tu cliques et après tu as
paramètres en bas
là
par exemple je peux écrire
et le troisième onglet c'est pas
historigine navigation c'est images et
fichier en cash tu le sélectionne
effacer
OK
images de fichiers en cache
moi
au pire au pire tu as perdu tes mots de
passe pas
alors ça tu sais que je vais mettre une
heure sur chaque site pour vous rappeler
de mes trucs
allez je vais
choisir ouais mais ils sont une
navigation ça paraît en fait je m'en
fous de mon historique
j'ai effacé
du coup du coup
je remercie pour votre aide donc on
espère que maintenant j'ai encore un bug
je vais actualiser la page juste pour
être sûr que ça n'arrive plus
normalement ça n'arrive plus
voilà si j'ai un bug les gars
donc j'ai cinq douteux et donc là il a
juste fou des trois
dans mon texte là on voit que j'ai 5 et
écrit en orange
avant je n'avais pas en rangement mais
normalement il est censé être ou pas
j'avoue que je regarde rarement sur
chaise comme tu veux que je regarde sur
le mien
ben
[Musique]
event
qui va commencer bientôt on se le fait
en parallèle
moi aussi j'ai moi j'ai des coups bleus
orange aussi ouais
ça y est je suis tout neuf là
donc les blancs sont mieux mais ici tout
va arriver ils ont 30 minutes pour jouer
25 coups les blancs sont mieux mais ça
reste très compliqué
enlève l'ordi du coup maintenant
tu vois il était en rouge mais si je
fuir je l'ai plus je pense
qui sont un petit peu à la mode dans un
moment tu vois les les manœuvres comme
ça la partie de fil rouge jaune
non ça me rend fou
[Musique]
ok donc voilà on résumait déjà eu deux
matchs ne le rapporte cawana à Carola
était mieux avec les Noirs mais je
pleutre
guéri est complètement gagnant contre
carcène mais bon ils font quand la finir
mais bon il y a eu un coup ou pas j'ai
pas vu non
il est en pleine déprime
ouais
le cache regarde s'il y a pas le
problème de vidéo ça pourrait changer
non
malheureusement vous n'êtes pas des
génies à ce point non j'ai trois caméras
j'ai le dos de caresses et j'ai les deux
caméras
mais on voit Kemer et on voit et on voit
dit voilà
il se passe quoi sur bcbc fou A3 tu vois
la tête de guéri ou pas
[Musique]
je sais pas comment il va pouvoir parce
que à la fin je vais prendre C5 il faut
prendre ces trois Tourbet 8
bcbc X3
en fait
de défendre quoi moi
[Musique]
j'ai pas vu la ligne
après échec ça va quand même échanger
quelques pièces
tu préfères garder les pièces parce que
Ben toi qui
fait des menaces
et du coup et qui aime du cavalier à 4
qui est passé des bilans derrière les
idées de taper sur ces cinq aussi
et pas pensé aux parents de ce qui est
sûr c'est que je ferais faut attendre
tu peux vérifier mais c'est le numéro 1
je pense que ça va être le meilleur coup
aussi
mais ouais pour moi c'est pas le plus
logique je ferais fois 300 réfléchir ok
ils ont Torcé 7 x 3 tours C7 et là on va
réfléchir
tomber 8
il est pas si content que ça mais
pourtant c'est un coup hyper humain en
fait non mais c'est sûr que c'est
cavalier aussi tu défends là mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas grand chose
je gagne déjà une pièce
il y a toujours une heure où
il me donne toutes ces pièces je joue au
qui perds
je sais pas trop où ça fait peur
c'est pas encore
[Musique]
c'est pas débile OK
ah je regardais tu reprends les quatre
pour la blague
avec
qui est B5 bouge la tour
ça c'est 6
et du coup tu vas pas ici tu vas
peut-être fait 17 erreurs
ça gagne tout de suite pour prendre des
cartes
en 8
ah bon donc
je réponds plus mais vous avez compris
l'idée
OK et c'est x 3
ça veut dire qu'il tourne cette paire en
force donc il faut donner le pion c'est
la partie
tout en haut quoi quand nous on le fait
j'ai une question contre Magnus la gagne
ou pas celle-là
ça dépend aussi de la confiance que vous
avez en vous parce que là où vous êtes 4
même plus maintenant
vous avez une position qui est gagnante
en fait ça dépend pas de vous enfin ça
dépend pas de personne pardon ça dépend
de vous en fait parce que en fait ce que
je bagarre ok est-ce que j'arrive à
gagner une partie gagnante est-ce que tu
arrives à jouer le bon coup en fait
parce que tu lui caresses Mathieu ou ou
que tu joues dans le chat en offense je
le connais bien et ben en fait
normalement pour gagner il faut que je
lis beaucoup quoi on nous propose
Emmanuel
mais ça perd à cause de fou prend aussi
OK
après le fait que tu sais que tu me
caresse ça peut te faire douter le
problème c'est psychologiquement
alors c'est toujours contre un mec qui
est moins fort que toi bah ça te parti
même s'écarcelles en face mais qui se
cache que la gagner
mais si je le vois il en face de moi
c'est moi c'est moi qui l'ai
donc l'idée ça doit être Torcé 8 alors
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur coup
d'ailleurs vu la jauge pour C8 cavaliers
la torrent
mais il peut pas aller n'importe où
parce que sur ça je vais avoir du
alors cavalier à 4
tu peux avoir des meilleurs finales mais
je vois pas de gain clean peut-être
cavalier à 4 maintenant mais ça me
paraît pas hyper clean parce que je veux
dire
l'élimination qui marche pas
si quel est le 6 pouces et 6 pour jouer
le cahier des cinq il faut prendre ces
trois il faut prendre tout pour
apprendre
[Musique]
vous allez m'entendre donc
si je pensais ici à Cabello 4
[Musique]
un peu compliqué là en plus si pour le
mot de passe
c'est bon je pense c'est mieux en fait
ce qui est proposé
ça paraît après pousser cinq je serai
pas surpris que ça gagne mais quel A4
j'aime bien l'idée parce que en fait tu
te tu t'enlèves le gros problème pendant
le seul thème qu'on a pour les Noirs
c'est ce qui est cette emprise
[Musique]
on fait juste fou prendre maintenant
donc il faut prendre le 6 bon c'est pas
obligé mais bon
ça c'est efficace pour ainsi
quand même
mais si la gagne contre une partie
longue et là il lui reste 37 minutes
en cavalière
mais je peux faire aussi que les
Français 5 et qui avait eu 4
pour moi ça gagne une qualité la partie
il a une bonne position il est hyper en
confiance il a il fait un bon début de
tournoi
on ce qu'il va je pense qu'il va gagner
je pense que ça va gagner en tout cas
ça donne quoi on a eu une nulle de stock
contre
Harmonia on avait une nulle de rapport
car voilà
et du coup il nous reste tout le reste
il a pris ses cinq du coup
tu es là-bas
ouais mais ça a l'air quand même assez
fort quoi parce qu'en fait si tu fais
cavalier aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on a dit
on l'avait rien dit mais juste comme la
barre est remontée on avait juste
mieux de on n'a pas on n'a pas géré la
tour comme tout à l'heure
mètre 80 c'est pas terrible
[Musique]
j'ai dansé avec lui à la salle à manger
avec lui maintenant
attends donc faut prendre le 6/3 prend
est-ce qu'il y a un gain ça ça doit
rendre fou s'il y a pas de gain vas-y
regarde droit
c'est obligé
comment tu gagnes là
j'y crois pas moi j'ai l'impression que
ça gagne de partout quoi
mais c'est là je pense
j'y ai pas pensé quai français 5 je
bouffe là
il y a encore là
ça a l'air d'être foutu partout mais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça me rendrait fou si je
trouve pas de gain ici
[Musique]
pour la blague non
ou pas
ça peut être une blague sympa
pour voir les autres parce que là
si c'est bien joué mais il faut prendre
ça marche non
mais bon bon
ça peut être égal quoi
il y a rien
alors on a du coup
qui a des problèmes
[Musique]
c'est pour ton match de championnat du
monde que tu joues au 4 il dit ouais
mais
une épaule il s'est mis à jouer des
cartes avant que moi je commence à jouer
au 4
qui partira
mais là les Noirs maintenant ça ils ont
réussi à
bien calculer et puis on prend un sein
qui apprend à 4
ok donc ça on annonce pas très
intéressant max
il était dans le dur et ça va beaucoup
mieux
il y a un énorme coup rouge maintenant
qu'on voit les couleurs non
à mon avis il a oublié que H6 ça
marchait
quoi
tu peux être un peu mieux dans la finale
avec les Blancs c'est blanc qui pousse
un peu faible donc c'est vrai que c'est
du mal parce que j'ai pas d'âme des si
c'est ça
un truc comme ça
on s'en sortir
c'est toujours ce sentiment que c'est
dur en pratique à cause de tout ça quoi
mais
[Musique]
non moi je prends ça en fait si tu joues
une finale la structure se passera
donc on a quoi d'autre
Kemer a réglé ici c'est vrai que ça fait
très longtemps c'est pas la partie qui
nous a IP ou mon camion donc là
je pense qu'il a il attend qu'il se
décape pour pour
le mec fait tout pour paraisser 4 parce
qu'en fait le plan des blancs c'est de
faire C4 mais si tu fais ces quatre le
fousser réveil et du coup les Noirs ils
disent bah du coup j'ai pas j'ai pas
intérêt de perdre du temps je vois 6
sachant que ton plan est basé sur ces
quatre quoi donc c'est
ça c'est
du bon côté de l'égalité on va dire
Evan Forrest Gucci donc je crois qu'il a
bien joué gokash il a trouvé ce roi des
pour le Red merci à toi
merci beaucoup donc voilà c'est génial
là faut le monde tu peux le montrer aux
gens
on voit un grand
position on a l'impression que que
c'est normal mais en fait regardez ce
qu'il a fait il avait cette position
avec les noirs
[Musique]
un coup pour profiter durant des 7 quoi
et
pas forcément les ruptures qui font que
tu vas réussir donc faut voir E5 ça a
pas l'air de marcher
[Musique]
peut-être d'ailleurs ce qui est un thème
comme souvent que tu veux faire
peut-être c'est pas
trop de pièces qui te gêne non il y a ça
en l'air comme nom
donc F3
je crois par exemple à la place de trois
roi D7 est-ce que je peux en profiter
pour jouer
[Musique]
vraiment jamais pour le coup
mais bon
[Musique]
il y a
cahier des cinq ou qui est F5
[Musique]
pas le temps en fait de faire tout ça et
moi
[Rires]
pour lui
je peux je peux changer mais c'est pas
le navigateur le problème c'est que
[Rires]
on se repose la question en fait
il menace et ton seul coup c'est fou
français 3 ici
il faut changer des pièces mais bon la
part de fou et le roi au centre
[Musique]
le concours de marche il le gagne très
très facile quand il y a pas Maxime
[Musique]
je peux absolument rien y faire là
non je viens de faire un truc de toutes
les caméras
on va rester un peu je peux avoir
ça montre à quel point
[Musique]
je peux pas savoir laquelle marche tout
est supprimé une par une pour
[Musique]
la mettre
ah oui donc là on s'en fout
re maintenant mais en fait c'est
Étienne qui fait le title c'est pas
possible
ils viennent m'envoyer une photo de
l'hôpital
j'en ai une elle est pas mal
vas-y je vais essayer celle-là
attends
il y a bien
pour quand on va pas ici
par exemple que je la programme elle a
disparu
j'en avais trois j'ai fait un truc j'en
ai eu plein
et tant que je le fasse j'en ai zéro
donc là je l'ai même plus la caméra
qu'on avait de base là vous la voyez ou
pas la caméra sur le chat
ça marche à toi
c'est assez bizarre parce que du coup ça
fait ça j'ai jamais vu une autre caméra
on le voit mais on va pas très très bien
mais on le voit un peu
comme c'est que tu as 15 quand je la
mets là elle marche
on voit rien oui mais en fait moi je le
fais cacher parce que si je le montrais
ça serait il y aura un bordel en fait
la caméra est là mais du coup
je vois son genou donc ça sert à rien
là elle arrive où il vient de jouer
comme ça
en fait quand c'est tellement
envoyé un
peu voilà mais sinon j'ai pas mieux
là tu as fait n'importe quoi
c'est une autre tu vas plus que une
caméra ouais j'en mets d'autres mais il
faut savoir les faire un marché et en
fait elle marche quand elle veut tu peux
juste changer la position de l'échiquier
parce qu'il y a eu un coup pardon
et en prise
c'est étonnant
attends ce que je vais faire
tu vois un problème à la prise ou oui
j'ai la caméra
[Musique]
je bois un pion je le prends
ben ouais
est-ce que vous prend des 6 gagne je
vois pas
non tac
j'ai une meilleure
je vous ai mis la caméra ça a mis ou pas
ça va venir ça va venir
à Nice à tomber la veste pour C8 jouer
tempo
donc là il attaque une pièce en un coup
il a un pion de moins paire de fou
c'est tellement gagnant facile
techniquement
que même toi tu la gagne
non mais
[Musique]
je suis en train de me prendre même ça
tu fais fou B4 ça gagne encore
pas mal
qui était 54
moi j'aime bien ça c'est scolaire quoi
même quand de Magnus de la gaine avec
maso en photo dans le maso il a gagné
un peu mais en fait il voulait se dire
que les bons coups tu as gagné quoi de
plus
oui
un pion il avait peur de foudre
il y a des cloches de partout et
tu vois c'est pire encore que tout ça
quoi
par contre parrain moi aussi il est pas
mal en terme de marche chaque fois on le
voit peu importe le sens de la caméra il
est toujours là c'est vrai c'est vrai il
s'est tout le temps et surtout qui
marche il fait des trucs
qu'on aille voir bien sûr position qui
qui je le sais qu'être même la caméra si
vous voulez des régies
tu prends des risques là
et il a faim et pour moi c'est réglé ici
positionnement c'est chelou
tu as vu ce qu'il a fait genre il a fait
le tour des 8 c'est cavalier F5 il a
jamais il pouvait jouer ici il pouvait
jouer à 6 non il dit vas-y laisse-moi
faire j'en étais là moi
il a raison
mais bon du coup ça va faire nul c'est
pas très intéressant
le plus dur est passé
il est il est très très concret
apparemment
moi tu sais ce qui me ferait peur ici
mais ça doit pas marcher
j'aurais peur de tout droit vas-y essaie
ça marche pas
ok ici j'ai plusieurs cours
[Musique]
de contrôler de menacer qui prend le 5
mais
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est vraiment une menace
plus
je me lasse pas directement quelque
chose
après ça ça mais non mais moi
[Musique]
j'aurais pas osé jouer B4 tours
B4
je reviens B4 la position
qui propose ok
je sais pas ce que ça vaut
ainsi si tu fais dame D1 et C2 ici c'est
vrai que ça se regarde
c'est quelqu'un le propose dans le chat
[Musique]
il faut trouver le bon ordre
position très drôle
non mais là ça doit gagner
en plus
ok moi je pense que
4 en fait ton problème si c'était ma
première idée mais tu peux montrer que
ça marche pas
je prends
voilà tu peux pas défendre mais
imaginons que même était possible
j'aurais eu échec et dames
donc du coup dans ma carte c'était pour
contrôler ces deux
tu me fais ces deux je te mange si tu me
fais dame D1 donc c'était ça peut-être
la personne proposée pense que tu perds
peut montrer Dame des rois h2c2 qui
avait lieu 5
pas sûr de moi
j'ai quand même et
j'ai surement maths
on n'a pas vu on n'a pas l'évaluation
nous donc après B4
non non d'ailleurs mais c'est très
tentant c'est toujours pas ça
il va te manger là donc il faut faire
quelque chose en fait
ah oui tu as raison en fait le mec il
peut pas le rater presque
ok
[Musique]
c'était toujours pas intéressant les
Noirs avaient réalisé
ça a bougé mais on peut regarder
peut-être un petit peu
il se passe quoi si Je bouge le cavalier
que je fais le 5
ici c'est pas mal ça menace la
fourchette
après je sais pas si il est bien placé
ici
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
on a besoin de forêt ce cookeh qui nous
a pas trop intéressé c'est une position
il y avait toutes les pièces sur les
chiens il y a encore pas longtemps
ok ça c'est simplifier les blancs
l'avantage de la paire de fou non
ils ont joué que 26 coups pourtant ils
ont accéléré donc ils étaient un peu en
retard donc il a fait des cinq pour se
libérer il y a eu un échange massif
donc il est à l'avantage de la paire de
fou ça me semble solide bon les blancs
sont toujours un poil mieux on pouvait
pas reprendre du fou il y avait ces cinq
empris je me rends compte
moi on prend toujours les blancs on a de
fou en théorie mais nul ne serait pas
très logique non
Forest et donc le grand format et donc
du coup
à 7
c'est là que j'étais en train de
réfléchir tout à l'heure
quel est le plus précis
est-ce que c'est fou B4
ou c'est pas ça
[Musique]
marche vas-y tu peux regarder
on prend un 4
vous prend des 6
on va prendre le 7
du coup c'est à dire que tu peux pas
aller faire ça donc tu dois aller en E7
au coup d'avant
faut prendre C8 on prend un deux
et tomber 7
plutôt bien ça ça a la tête d'un truc
gagnant techniquement
peut-être plus tard
pas forcément obligé d'ailleurs mais
la personne qui va perdre
celle qui devrait perdre donc
oui oui c'est la même idée ça marche
Cyril
parce que sur ça je vais leur montrer
important échec ça c'est une fausse
découverte parce que je mets la tour
devant une fausse découverte
c'est un thème tactique normalement te
fait gagner à quelque chose tactiquement
du coup c'est une fausse découverte
c'est une découverte mais ça reste une
découverte mais elle est pas bonne
ce qu'il y a d'autres gains
c'est le premier coup qui vient à
l'esprit non sur qui avait la 4 tu peux
montrer la position actuelle il y a
quatre qui est B6 fourchette
et
tu menaces aussi de revenir avec ton
four en B4 et rejouer sur ce clouage
non mais c'est complètement gagnant
j'ose pas regarder l'évaluation
alors 40
[Musique]
et si moi je mets le mien
plus 5
toi tu es plus 5
il avait les blancs
c'est des fois tu peux avoir des
positions qui sont moches mais tu dis tu
t'accroches tu dirais j'ai un plan de
plus j'ai un plan de plus là
ok donc sur E5
il ajoute 5 ok j'avais pas vu c'est bien
joué parce que si on prend des quatre
temps prend tu centralises vachement
plus
ouais
il va la tenir je pense Ding mais ouais
pas une très bonne partie c'est fait
neutraliser dans l'ouverture
j'essaye mais ça vous va pas
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on fait ça quand
c'est les zinox ouais
après 45 il va peut-être pas être en
direct
juste pour
la lumière
la caméra de
non mais bien joué bien joué la partie
de son adversaire
mais celle-là là on voit bien Garden
mais par contre je sais qu'il est tout
petit
là pour le coup vous avez bien voir ça
Carson qui se balade guérir pardon qui
se balade à côté et le fond vert c'est
tu peux incruster des choses dedans
c'est ça l'idée
que je la flemme mais puis en plus toi
comme tu l'as pas bon ça fait un peu
à la maison il y a eu du vélo sur ce
canapé
[Musique]
alors il y a eu un coup dans la partie
de Magnus du coup comme il y a un zoom
on a vu un coup
il a joué un coup de cavalier en mode
desperados
[Musique]
on va essayer de trouver le bien tout
seul
moi j'avoue que foubeccat
[Musique]
IVe
il va aller il va aller là
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr
il est là
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça c'est complètement gagnant technique
mais elle revient il doit y avoir plus
clean
mais fou
tu vois comment il calcule quand même
et si je fais tour BC1
prise c'est ce qu'il veut
juste ça
parce que si tu me faisais
la boîte
ça marche pas ok donc tomber c'est un je
pense c'est le coup
et non on va juste la jauge mais bon je
pense ça gagne
je sais pas pourquoi ça gagne pas ça
non
il a joué ou pas non il a besoin ça a
l'air très très dur
elle est complètement nulle limite
enlève la m'énerve en fait
je peux pas laver en fait ah sinon ça te
décale tout non je peux l'enlever mais
en fait on m'a demandé de la garder
ce qui se passe
les Américains mais pas les français
on peut faire un
un
prédiction si vous voulez
un sondage si vous voulez
le meilleur
qu'on a mentionné que le met pas
8 ah oui c'est joli regarde
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on prend la jauge ou pas les
quatre huit donc à la place de tomber
c'est un
bk38 attends il y avait les points
qu'on a loupé évidemment
faut B 4 8
et c'est 5
et prends ces 5 faut prendre ces quatre
les Belges ne veulent pas la tête
vous vous la voyez même pas la jauge
c'est ça
si vous changez de vues vous allez la
voir
du coup je vais l'enlever
je pense que tu donnes la chose à
n'importe quel genre de 2007 je pense
c'est bien joué c'est tellement bon
c'est ce que j'ai dit non finalement je
joue ouais ouais non mais c'est bon je
pense qu'il y a plein de coups très très
bien en fait
c'est pas mal parce qu'on peut parce que
[Musique]
un peu mais
vu que la partie
susceptible de se terminer bientôt
c'est pas
[Musique]
bon
en fait il y avait une minute
donc non non
c'est la meilleure chance non
mais tout à l'heure on avait vu une
variante au moins tu avais bouffé le
pion
et c'est juste fini tôt on attend juste
l'abandon
ouais cette caméra elle est pas mal pour
une fois on va voir l'image est nette en
plus
merci beaucoup
et d'ailleurs je te l'ai dit de te
rendre je sais pas si les gens ont vu
j'ai fait une vidéo ce matin et j'ai
trouvé une énorme erreur dans notre
analyse live
oups un petit on pense que les noirs
sont mieux et c'est plus deux et à la
place il y a un coup on pensait que ça
marchait pas c'est moins 2 c'était quoi
tu m'as dit tout à l'heure c'était sur
la prison 4 dans la partie de Carona
en fait d'ailleurs on avait compris
qu'il fallait pas prendre le cadre mais
pas pour la bonne raison en fait
[Musique]
il y a tellement de mous dans ces vidéos
dans ces lives à cause de la cadence
mais d'ailleurs intéressant c'est même
pas sûr non parce que Van forest buka
chiant ouais Prague pas grand chose
comme on peut je pense qu'il faut aller
voir par un
mec
quelques petits problèmes pratiques et
encore une fois il se défend et
on peut aller voir mais du coup si on
change là vous allez voir la position en
tout petit
on reste sur 4 scène là c'est la
position équilibrée sur notre ça va
faire nul même s'il y a une petite
pression quand même pour les
les blancs sans doute mettent la
pression alors on s'est arrêté là on
l'avait vu
c'était le meilleur coup avec cavalier
7 qu'on a pas vu et là il dit tu
reprends F6
on reprend F6 dans 8
dame D1
range de C2
[Musique]
pour faire une fourchette en détroit du
coup il a une finale de dame qui en plus
OK
je sais pas si vous voyez la différence
en fait ces deux choses différentes
moi j'ai déjà fait des commentaires où
on a l'ordinateur qui tourne donc je le
fais très rarement parce que j'aime pas
parce que du coup tu réfléchis même plus
là en fait juste on sait que la position
est à peu près équilibrée ça on a la
jauge on la voit déjà pas vraiment bien
donc on sait pas du tout quel est le
coup c'est quand même différent
[Musique]
et ben
ils le savent avant les joueurs quoi
tu peux venir dans le live
ouais ça va faire un
jouet pour
[Musique]
ça
F4 et tu vas pas gagner le 3 contre 3
pas non plus déconner en fait
que tu as proposé en une demi-seconde
et on pense qu'on va avoir des nuls de
partout
sans doute nul mais il est un peu moins
bien qui est mère égale qui peut un peu
jouer contre lui je pense à limite le
reste dans sa famille abdos
en fait on est cloué à la fin
manger ces quatre dessus parce que
là j'aurais un tour 31
du coup je peux pas manger en C4 même si
on dirait on pourrait croire qu'on peut
manger le cavalier en fait non il y a
des cloises un peu partout
je pense
tu peux montrer peut-être si vous fait
prendre ces quatre
je te reconnais cette
pour être sûr
bref bien sûr que la tour je vais la
manger deux fois mais dans les deux sens
ça gagne aussi parce qu'il y avait une
découverte à la fin en fait
il doit bouger le roi tu peux pas aller
sur la colonne D
un coup d'avant
tu peux pas aller en D8
parce que je fais faut prendre ces
quatre et tu reprends des entrepreneur
c'est sur échec
j'ai peur réfléchi
[Musique]
même si tu joues H4 dans la position à
la place de football
[Musique]
ça a l'air d'être la meilleure case
donc là il y a peut-être pas de gain
direct ah il y a peut-être le coup de
tout à l'heure ce qui rend marche et
c'est 5
je comprends ces quatre
pour prendre et le truc c'est que tu
menace fou blessant
en fait sur le long terme seront au
centre et ces pièces qui
parce que c'est pas le moment
son grand défaut c'est qu'il détestent
les contre-jour ouais il veut il est
trop perfectionniste
même si c'est gagnant hein
il est pas il est pas sur un
sans qu'il sait qu'il est
ils sont au quantième coup en
31 donc
pour être sûr donc 9 minutes
ça nous semblait comme la seule case
pour pas perdre tout de suite
et la tête du mec surprise
[Musique]
on va voir en tout cas
le moins convaincu parce qu'on a dit ton
prise et B6 pour jouer
[Musique]
mais t'as pas remarqué que ça arrive
quand tu mets beaucoup de coup dans une
partie
quand tu l'analyse beaucoup
toujours la question
par exemple
[Musique]
de quoi
bien qu'il y a un mec dans le public
[Musique]
mal c'est on peut la remontrer c'était
fou c'est quatre
C4 kb6 ça c'est un joli
ça permet de garder le fou au moins
après c'est juste c'est gagnant
technique
et on va peut-être que là cette
pollution il l'ajoute comme par terre on
a peut-être que plutôt est-ce que ça
marche mon idée je suis pas sûr
et c'est ça
pour des C7
et mon problème c'est que j'ai pas
trouvé de bien ici
tu manques de casse avec tes tours
puis j'ai aussi un coup qui peut arriver
c'est pas très F4 un jour
quand même à la caméra
Carlson aille calcul c'est horrible
quand tu calcules et que tu vois tout
paires
là tu pries pour que le mec joue le
moins mauvais mais juste tout gagne
tellement
c'est la variante principale de quoi à
de l'ordi peut-être
on n'a pas l'ordi on fait sans ordi donc
c'est pas mal ton X5 que j'avais pas
pensé
en fait surtout à 4 en fait je peux te
présenter après je suis pas sûr de F4
pour le con parce que
tu vois et bon
évaluer à 6 j'échange tout
échange tout ces quatre à quatre à cinq
et final paire de fou pied en plus
peut-être
le roi passait pas non plus hein ouais
mais je contrôle
ok non mais tu gagnes est-ce que tu veux
qu'on aille voir ce qui reste s'il y a
des trucs importants après on aurait
bien voulu voir l'abandon mais pour
l'instant il ne vient pas donc on peut
regarder en même temps et garder la
caméra
5 bon ça sera pas trop avancé
ça doit tenir faut juste faire gaffe au
temps ils ont 7 minutes pour le coup
il a raison je suis un peu comme quand
tout est gagnant et que tu es
perfectionniste tu veux pas laisser le
contre-jour c'est hyper chiant ouais
il peut craquer on dit rien
il peut en fait tellement de gains
prendre
des mauvaises décisions et bon
donc là
c'est complètement
c'est un peu face à l'énonçons son pouce
en fait des Noirs poussent maintenant
quand même et puis
pas très bien ce que je fais là
il fait des têtes
on peut aller voir
donc on a dit top France C4
donc l'idée c'est 5 et il y a un clouage
le cabinet peut pas bouger
encore plus fort
il y a 6 minutes contre 9
à peu près
il reste 6 coups
à les caméras il y a un petit décalage
donc là nous on pensait à tour C7
si tu fais fout des 6 je pense que je te
fais genre fou F3
ou des six fois pour clouer vraiment de
partout quoi
donc là on a trouvé deux îles toi tu as
des fois 5 moi j'ai dit Torcé un pour
tout échanger
pour le public Géraldine la réponse
[Musique]
c'est pas bête l'idée c'est de se
retourner 7 tu veux je fous
[Musique]
mais il y a aussi F4 qui se regardant
mais bref 4 je crois pas parce que je
t'aime bien blinder ici et toutes ces
trois jours aux parents E7 et F8
c'était pas débile je pense ouais non
mais je je le sais mais pour apprendre
ton dessin
ça doit pas marcher
qui gagne
ok si c'est dur avant
tu as pas intérêt à chercher des trucs
comme ça
il y a peu de temps la pendule et encore
5 coups à faire
bon moi je sais qu'elle est partie je
vais commenter demain matin
belle partie en tout cas
je pense qu'il va abandonner
je pense que je dois bien abandonner
l'anus qui prie
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a comme cool
je vais juste perdre la qualité et puis
continuer avec torcer un ça a l'air
complètement terminé
[Musique]
c'est la même chose j'attends pareil
sauf que du coup
il a plus la tour quoi
il va engueuler ses préparateurs après
honnêtement
le choix il a validé et là ça donne
vraiment l'impression qu'il s'est pas
rappelé jusqu'au bout parce qu'on a vu
avec le support ordinateur et surtout la
partie par correspondance parce que pour
les dieux entre guillemets c'est censé
être
égalait pas du tout apparemment
ça a laissé B4 c'est B4 a été saisi
maintenant je suis en train de regarder
la caméra
il dit il lui reste 4 minutes pour
quelques coups mais le problème c'est
que je n'ai pas de coup tu es là
je fais un petit tour moi-même pour
l'instant je pense que tout va faire nul
il y a que 10 il y a que pratique qui
peut jouer un peu je pense je reste un
peu mais objectivement je pense que ça
va faire trois nuits enfin trois
positions qui qui vont
[Musique]
et je vous dirai ça demain en vidéo
je pense qu'il va même pas jouer un coup
je vois one lost
on va le voir la caméra je pense
pas très belle partie à partir de
l'erreur et d'ailleurs l'ouverture est
bonne l'ouverture est très bonne du coup
parce que du coup
ils sont en train de discuter ah il
sourit
carlsonade du monde plus cool en fait
j'ai l'impression en fait je me trompe
mais qu'il le prend beaucoup moins à
cœur quoi
ils discute mais il y a que guérit qui
parle
enfin ça y est
allemand logique mais il laisse B4 c'est
fini en fait tu peux laisser juste ce
moment au 22e coup
on avait toujours une partie par
correspondance et moi j'avais toujours
dans mes analyses de 2014 ce qui était
drôle d'ailleurs
et qui est Descartes est mauvais parce
que B4 en fait on a même pas besoin de
défendre des 7 parce qu'on ouvre la
position totalement
et on nous a fait chercher on a mis un
peu de temps mais on a trouvé le coupe
B4 quand on a vu que la jauge excitant
on a trouvé
il sait qu'il a fait quelque part
un B4 très bien joué en fait il a saisi
et après il a d'ailleurs il a très bien
fini
il a joué les coups percutants il a
gagné en ligne
ok belle partie
à commenter demain matin alors que je
viens de faire annuler on peut aussi
aller voir je vais remettre notre notre
caméra et notre vue aussi où j'ai 5 un
peu douteux avait été joué
de quoi alors attends je vais juste
regarder ce que j'ai comme caméra
malheureusement j'ai aucune caméra sur
les parties qui restent
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé il y a eu
propositions
oui c'est moi qui qui suis actif en fait
un moment critique dans la partie mais
après il a très bien joué le roi des 7 3
C8 quand même
ça c'était quand même une belle manœuvre
à connaître
et pas tu trouves avec le ressent et tu
te fais attaquer là il a réussi à roquer
à la main comme on dit
donc ça là c'est bon du coup ben
toujours après qui met pressions un peu
un sording ce serait pas déjà gagné
H1 au tour 1
non ça marche pas
ça marche pas ça marche pas ça se
regarde
tu veux faire chaque d'abord
je préférerais
[Musique]
tu veux pas
il y a une pression quoi
sa position ce qu'on l'a pas vu depuis
un moment
il est comme ça
ouais c'est toujours égal qui joue
noir avec avec
la colonne C tout ça mais
quand même bien bien bloqueur des fois
on peut donner le pion B pour attaquer
F2 par exemple
nous le pouvons le forest on venait de
le dire oui
donc ok ça se passe pas très intéressant
à 200 euros bon alors il y a quand même
des petits réseaux de maths faire un
petit peu attention et de côté
il menace par exemple là c'est son ordre
de jeu je gagne torrent ou H24
j'ai 32
du coup je dois parler la menace quand
même hein
je pense
nul je prends et
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que je pose la question
c'est pour moi c'est pas évident
la blague du Mexicain était très bonne
est-ce que je peux changer mais sans
changer les dames peut-être
là pourquoi il a pas joué ça je tourne
un
il laisse le roi dans les courants d'air
et sachant que son adversaire une minute
pour deux coups
[Musique]
je peux te mater quoi
mais attention que si la tourelle part
il y a souvent des carpettes il reste
plus qu'un coup là
peut-être c'est 4
c'est quatre je peux pas partir avec
Madame sinon il y aura tout
me paraît cohérent
et puis
parce que c'est une vraie menace qu'on a
pas d'échec sur les cases noires
oui la finale tourne la tour la dame
prend roi H2 elle peut gagner pour les
blancs oh ça reste dur pour pousser les
pions
d'air tu as qu'un coup à jouer et tu
peux jouer un coup qui perd
très bien joué à il met la pression mais
il a raté on avait déjà vu au moins une
ou deux occases dans la partie
en la menace c'est dans G7 peut-être des
fois
dans le dur 19 secondes tu n'as pas la
caméra non
je peux essayer mais tout à l'heure j'ai
fait des manips mais
il ne regarde jamais l'échiquier c'est
un peu
il y a eu des simplifications
très dangereux pour les Noirs mais ça
doit aller objectivement mais ça fait
très peur moi j'aurais hyper peur avec
les mains
il veut je roi C6 qui est plutôt bien
joué je pense
ok donc celle-là peut être intéressant
faut savoir que merde il y a eu deux
trois couches j'ai vu à la caméra il
s'est levé donc en début ils ont passé
le contrôle
sur le pion F
non ok ça ça va faire nul Ding est-ce
qu'il a passé le contrôle est-ce qu'il
est toujours en danger
il est au 39
moi j'avais proposé de Tours qui me
semblait plus logique peut-être
pour prendre les 6 cavalier F3
avec l'idée H4 et peut-être ça peut nous
aider pour après aller manger le piment
en fait de quoi tout à l'heure à la
place
j'ai une caméra sur Abdou mais
par contre Ding
il a deux minutes ça demande pas la
caméra
non mais si je l'ai en plus mais
c'est pas laquelle qui marche
ça me rend fou
donc là il va y avoir le contrôle de
temps passé quasiment partout il va y
avoir un gros mou
en plus
il y a un mec
je sais pas à quel point il y a des
chances de gain pour les Noirs mais
très terrorisé
tu as rien de bien placé c'était
de la pendule
pour pour le chinois
ce qui me compliquer un problème sur
votre âme sur G5
ça peut ça peut aller vite mais
il y aura 50 secondes c'est ça et tout
le sens stressé il bouge partout regarde
il est pas il est pas à l'aise
il y a un truc
ça
sent la sapinette
et voir si je peux pas les manger le
pion je crois
c'est peut-être gagnant
chercher des petits réseaux mais je vois
rien
d'ailleurs tu sais quoi le super
ordinateur norvégien d'habitude il
s'arrête à la partie de
Magnus et là il a mis la partie Ding
pral Mandanda - 1,68 et c'est roi J6 h43
mais bizarre du coup
si tu peux pas revenir au coup d'avant
parce qu'apparemment c'était pas si
clair
[Musique]
en fait et faire H4
glu
roi des 7 l'évaluation tu veux 0,70
mais non mais l'ordi ne trouve pas
leur dire
franchement il y a quand même un monde
où ce matin
ça marche
d'accord
concours de marche ah oui non
[Musique]
c'est pas clair qui prend de l'avance
je le vois plus souvent debout que guéri
quand même
un guéri se lève vraiment tout le temps
mais c'est les nerfs
donc ouais ouais ouais
Mathieu après le diagnotte là donc il
est passé il a joué un coup
elle la pose on peut et là je vois
gestisseur moi je pense qu'il va la
gagner
5 et ça risque d'être difficile pour
pour
l'impression que ouais je vais te manger
les pions
mais
[Musique]
avoir
pour la poste si tu veux après je sais
pas si ma fille va me laisser revenir
c'est le seul problème comme tu veux en
fait moi bon je vais juste partir alors
pendant quelques secondes
chez moi il pleut j'ai mon linge qui
d'accord
ouais 3 minutes je vais sortir mon linge
dehors et je reviens d'accord à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est reparti pour la fin de cette
quatrième ronde avec
du coup on disait attends
au moins tu as la caméra ouais je l'ai
perdu
et donc du coup avec on avait dit H4
si il fait le tour des 7
faire attention à des fois on a tout est
propre
on reprend H4
ok d'accord
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est
chez moi
micro
[Musique]
ok le chat réagit à fond là
5 il a pas le temps des 7
ok qui veut revenir avec cabinet
par rapport à la pose
ensemble
comme on dit
que je force tout recadre ah non pas du
tout n'importe quoi
E4 je fais tout 3
c'est 4 qui essaie de
tu as perdu
pour moi
[Musique]
ça je prends
un roi G4
parce que là
[Musique]
F4 qui est des 5
peut manger là aussi même faire du
cavaler des cinq tu vas finir par manger
à tous les pions du coup surtout
dans ce forcer ou pas ça
[Musique]
en fait c'est gagné en ligne non vas-y
reviens
ok
il y a échec et C5 et c'est fini
pour vous je t'en prends un cadre tu en
prends un 5
qui fait donc je menace 3 si je fais que
G4 je peux je reprends H4
les rois G6
[Musique]
parce qu'en plus regarde pour là
en fait
je me garde peut-être
j'ai qu'un placard
c'est quoi ton idée je sais pas
la fourchette ça peut arriver
il y a pas de il y a pas de matin il y a
autour de tout
[Musique]
ça ça permet
et donc le seul coup c'était du coup de
faire cavaler ces quatre est-ce que je
peux pas jouer C5
ou J6 ici
et manger là et garder un déplion passé
quoi
je vais pas te mentir je pense ça serait
très étonné que ce soit le meilleur
mais ok c'est pas si simple son idée
c'est juste de d'attendre à mon avis OK
ils ont échangé B contre F
ouais
pas très impressionnant et là
abdosotov il met une pression de fou
quoi
donc du coup ils ont vachement le temps
de réfléchir
c'est quoi l'idée sur taureau 2
chèques
parce que c'est bon je me retrouve mal
un jour
mais pour deux j'étais quand même hein
je l'ai vu au début
[Musique]
je peux pas jouer dans le B5
kete
[Musique]
est possible
je vois pas de gains
en fait pour récupérer la case là qu'on
avait pas avant
là c'est mat donc
j'ai pas vu de gain alors je te montre
ce que j'ai calculé de dame B7 roi C5
obligé sinon il attendait
6 et je vois pas de 15 trucs de l'espace
même moi qui peut qui peut je pour
gagner quoi
[Musique]
la courbe le truc c'est que tu vois pas
la différence entre -040 et
quand j'ai fait comme une belle analyse
en pensant que c'est au nord de jouer
ok dame
si je fais dans ma tête
je vais partir
ça faisait peur non en fait on pensait
que c'était gagnant on voit pas de gaz
sont intéressants
on a tendance à dire que ça va pour les
noirs
je garde
8 peut-être
en fait ça je me plainte et je t'embête
quoi mais je me laisse rien mais
comme tout rêve
trois C6
a perdu depuis longtemps
[Musique]
parce que mon roi va aller sur C6 donc
j'ai l'impression que tu as besoin de ta
dame pour m'embêter de ce côté-là mais
peut-être je me trompe
après
[Musique]
savoir si il va jouer
ciblage
on a dit taureau 3 et c'est 5 et
tu en penses
avec l'idée il y a plutôt des sets et
sur lequel F3
qui est machine François
non en fait ça fait longtemps que je le
suis avec sa course en Bullet
et
du coup pour lui c'est important il faut
pas jouer du vrai
[Musique]
ok donc tours
la plus intéressante parce que c'est là
il y a plus de chance de se tromper
il rejoint guéri en tête
Abdou
oui c'est ça ouais
mais j'ai pensé tout à l'heure mais je
pensais qu'il y a très chèques et moyen
de prendre sur un chèque l'option
raciste c'est pas sûr
tu vois
mais bon
plairement bien passé
et un super coup qu'on voit pas
ce n'est pas une grosse surprise
peut-être un coup juste un peu
j'y ai pensé mais
joue un coup mais genre tous deux
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que même
j'espère réussite en fait on s'en fout
quoi
[Musique]
c'est pas c'est pas le nombre d'options
qui compte c'est les plombs plus avancés
et là
le pion dangereux c'est pour ça quoi
c'est pas le pion de plus que j'ai en H3
on s'en [ __ ]
je vois pas le bon coup
de téléphone un ami bientôt ton F7 ça a
l'air gagnant mais on trouve pas
le début
sachant que tu veux
quoi en fait
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce que tu
gagnes 4
[Musique]
OK
et visiblement il a pas joué le plus
précis Abdou là le meilleur coup pour
lui c'est du B2 j'ai mon cou il a jeté
en cours
ça empêche pour eux
et ça garde les les idées d'attaque donc
pour rien c'est soit dame 5 bon ça c'est
en mode solide je peux comprendre mais
taureau dame G7 roi C6 d'abranger 6 fois
c'est 5 et tu as plus d'échec
franchement
humainement c'est pas facile
donc monter le roi C5 donner un pion je
pense pas que ça allait faire peur
donc il ajoute ton 4 on peut aller voir
on peut aller voir petit Prague
et sur cavalier
on va récupérer tous les pieds OK
c'est une vraie question
après le roi G5 sur G7 on bouge ton C7
H5 on est mieux
mais est-ce qu'on veut plus que ça
au plateau mais je voulais montrer je
sais pas si ça c'est possible parce que
lui aussi
que tu as pas ton G4 ici
ça marche pas
et des cinq tours des 7
j'arrive pas à le faire marcher ok donc
je peux pas jouer cahier des 5
cavalier à 6 peut-être
ça empêche toi 16h
[Musique]
en fait vas-y
c'est mieux mais juste pourquoi
pourquoi quand tu veux une ligne qui
gagne tu changes pour toi tu fais pareil
en partie ah oui moi je suis terrible
non mais tu es d'accord que en tant
qu'entraîneur c'est mon métier ça me
gêne
tout recettes 3 G6
ça ça me paraît bien clean
puis après tu regardes tu vas tout
manger à fur et à mesure et puis à
manger avec la tour c'est complètement
gagnant
assez facile j'ai l'impression
est-ce que tu peux le faire mais arrêtez
trouve un truc qui gagne changer pas
un gars
après toi
après ça
ici
je vais t'attaquer G7 après ça peut
transposer
en fait pas manger HK ça serait chelou
aussi
je crois que j'ai pas mieux là
madame si tu veux j'ai le coup de
paramètres
[Musique]
il a joué quoi
donc pour expliquer pour protéger le
pion on veut jouer 3 F4
et les 5
la Tour partira et du coup moi je
mangeais un peu tous les pions quoi
au moins
je pense
[Musique]
ça c'est pas bien pour la confiance ça
marche pas du monde bah il a voulu
réaliser dans l'ouverture
après il reste des parties encore mais
oui c'est un battant
[Musique]
c'est un miracle
surtout avec cette cadence si il y a 30
secondes tu peux l'arnaquer il a 30 il a
28 minutes 29 non mais en fait tu prends
même s'il est plus fort encore une fois
je veux des coups précis et tu as gagné
quoi
l'avantage quand on est à un certain
niveau
on peut jouer des bons coups le problème
c'est qu'on en fait moins souvent mais
je peux faire des parties où je fais que
des bons coups donc si je suis bien
maintenant ou dans un bon jour je peux
on peut pas être n'importe qui
des très forts
qui sont meilleurs que moi en fait aux
échecs faut pas remettre en cause gagner
pas dire que tu es meilleur
Magnus gagne tout c'est parce qu'il est
meilleur et aujourd'hui il a perdu
contre guéri ça peut dire qu'il est
moins bon
mais ce qui est dur c'est de l'accepter
quand tu joues quand tu perds une partie
te dire ok j'ai perdu non pas parce que
je suis merde ou je suis nul ou j'ai pas
j'ai mal joué le jeu est tellement
compliqué
il n'y a pas un jeu de 30 secondes
parcours ah si si bien sûr
la cadence c'est 1h40 pour 40 coups à
7h30 je vais manger
une soupe
donc la cadence c'est 1h40 pour 40 coups
plus 50 minutes au 40e
pour 20 coups
et ensuite un quart d'heure
[Musique]
moi je suis pour un truc assez rare je
suis pour 15 minutes au 40e coup c'est
juste pour aller faire pipi
donc il nous reste donc deux parties
Ding en grand danger
contre Prague le jeune et abdominaux
j'ai mentionne
au début n'hésitez pas le bon même si je
t'aime pour
donc
on a juste les couleurs on voit que
c'est
et
bon déjà ok même si il avait tout
recettes
c'est le deuxième
non c'est
pas simple
je garde en fait les options et j'ai
plein de trucs
moi j'adore les parties longues je sais
que toi tu es pas trop comme ça bandit
non plus je suis fan juste là je trouve
trop longue
dans les parties
ça dépend il y a des périodes je suis
lentes
c'est assez rare quand même que
généralement je suis en route avec note
ça c'est rare
mais peu et du coup qu'on change avec
notre souvent ben je suis stressé
parce que parce que
ça dépend
qu'est-ce que je ferais ici
ok ça pose une question sur un coup un
petit peu de bulletin
parce que tu en penses
bien
ça a l'air très bizarre ce coup un très
suspect est-ce que je peux jouer dans
mes deux
S
le problème c'est que je me lasse pas
grand chose je crois après dame
[Musique]
ouais en fait l'idée de Mathieu depuis
le début c'est qu'il veut sacrifier le
pion pour gagner du temps en fait sur
l'attaque par exemple d'un F2 je
reprends un H3 échec je fais voilà et
non elle a pas aimé mais je t'explique
l'idée c'est que tu me laisses de manger
la tour et peut-être que tu peux avoir
cette menace là de la tour et en même
temps une attaque genre de massette un
truc ailleurs quoi et du coup ça peut
être sympa malheureusement là ici
je vois pas comment ça peut marcher
G7 et je rentre ma tortue
mais peut-être que tu peux jouer dame
ici
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu
c'est plus logique ça ça me fait même
techniquement 4
ok d'accord
en fait l'idée
je me lasse GH aïe
et dame D1 Tour Eiffel
il y a pas d'échec en D4 et je fais GH
c'est pas d'échec
encore mais là je vais juste maintenant
je vais attaquer de l'autre côté
il peut y avoir trois résultats
alors du coup le tatouage
ça a été
le 1700
mais du coup si je peux reprendre j'ai 5
au coup d'avant du coup
donc ça sent
[Musique]
plus net
H5 tours
[Musique]
et le malin parce qu'il y a eu la fuite
là
et après on pousse le pion h on va
manger eux
ça semble être gagnant bon après faut
toujours conclure c'est toujours le plus
dur il fait tomber la veste digne c'est
trop tard
pour cette journée
c'est quand même
avec ton B4 aussi des fois tu peux
manger à 4 ou même moi je crois
[Musique]
parce que j'ai un peu plus et en plus du
pion et ben il y a un pion faible en E3
il y a le roi qui est toujours
à surveiller il y a plein de thèmes avec
cavalistes sur le roi et peut-être aussi
avec avaler des cinq tour B4
cavalier F8 cavalier à 6 de gagner
facile plus j'y pense
et si je mange juste tu veux jouer ça et
mange à 4 donc 3 3
4 des fois je peux juste jouer ton
prochain
il y a peut-être moyen devant en fermer
cette cavalier
[Musique]
c'est parti
donc qui fait un bon début de tournoi
qui qui pour l'instant qui se battent
c'est un peu enfin c'est pas laborieux
mais juste c'est pas c'est pas
flamboyant mais il est là il se baille
quand il faut défendre il défend non
mais là dans la partie il a jamais été
vraiment exécuté donc bon
tu sens qu'il est en galère deux fois il
est moins bien avec les Blancs digne
avec
trouvé par Abdou
[Musique]
ça sent que c'est un coup un peu bizarre
trois parties décisive
et comme un gros gâchis de
dommage
qu'il a fait nul il aurait pu essayer de
jouer un peu et il s'est mis en mode
d'ailleurs je Prague dans un tournoi et
j'ai les Noirs égalise très facilement
et on commence à simplifier mais t'as
pas le droit de faire mieux le moins 30
couches pendant le tournoi et on se
regarde bon ben du coup on décide de
jouer un peu vite c'est pour faire nul
donc on joue vite tous les deux tu sais
c'est un centre d'enchaînement et on
voit une longue suite forcée les deux on
voit la même ligne et il annule à la fin
et au milieu de la ligne il joue son
coup il a pu s'apprené là il fait en
fait je venais de donner une pièce je
m'étais trompé dans l'ordre de coups et
comment il a joué vite parce qu'on
savait qu'on allait faire nul il a pas
mangé la pièce
très très bon quand même
et dans ce cas là si il mange la pièce
il mange la pièce quoi
vous êtes rien dit quoi
l'idée
du coup
[Musique]
qui arrive et en fait je voulais faire
de la marche 4 au début mais il y avait
le Tour Eiffel
qui permet de attirer le roi en bas
j'ai pas la ref pour moi ça gagne parce
que ça prend l'avantage net mais je
menace par
dans français 4
je pense en fait c'est vraiment un jeu
d'activité quoi là du coup avec ton
rachète et ben il nous laisse clairement
l'activité
la colonel
oui
il passe en fermer là-bas et nous il
nous laisse complètement tout le jeu
pour F4 tour des quatre la dame là
maintenant est mal placé il y a tout qui
en l'air on nous a proposé un truc tu
peux montrer au coup d'avant le droit C7
on nous a proposé pour prendre un H3
tour des trois pour empêcher le tour des
cartes
mais on pense
j'ai mis un truc
Kevin c'est ce qui fait il revient quand
il analyse il fait pas plus de coups il
revient il remet toujours la prison de
départ il repart à mon avis c'est quand
il y a trop de coups dans la ligne
ouais c'est ça quand tu vas sur la 5
la barre est d'accord c'est plus de ça
bon c'est pas en fait c'est la magie de
la barre ça a pas grand chose
de visu donc la tour des quatre a l'air
fort
il ajoute tout recettes notre ami digne
en Labé mentionné non
on avait dit on reprend G5 il y a aussi
G6 dans la même idée
plutôt que le pion h
ça marchera pas ça
va ça change pas le fondamentalement la
police
ok bon
ça va se décanter peut-être bientôt
ouais
qui a 15 minutes à la pendule enfin 16
30 33 pour Ding
et McDo slow ils ont 25 minutes chacun
ouais c'est qu'avant ce que sont quand
même infernales quoi ça va c'est très
très long quand même tout ça
en plus il y a un contrôle au centième
les gens sont je sais pas si ils savent
mais
dans 15 coups pour Abdou et 15 coups
aussi
dans 15 coups pour les deux parties et
ben on a un quart d'heure de rajout
encore une fois avec cette fois-ci soit
toujours 30 secondes par contre au début
jusqu'à la fin donc ça peut durer encore
un moment tout ça
ça peut durer encore un bon petit moment
mais normalement je pense que voilà
reprends le 5 jours par Prague
je pense que la partie de Prague va pas
encore très très longue je pense que
je suis d'accord mais d'ailleurs l'autre
rapide
ça peut être terminé très vite aussi
les gros modules mais bon
ce qui veut rien dire
que ça amène à la même chose prendre le
pion jet ou le Pione
on l'a oublié cette fois
pardon tout à l'heure on a pensé à 6
dans un truc similaire
[Musique]
parce qu'il est plus éloigné pour les
blancs en fait aller chercher
donc
la partie d'abdos on l'a pas
trouvé
parce qu'en fait sorte à la même finale
qu'avant
[Musique]
et tu parles à menace tout simplement
parce que du coup moi
parce que
oui c'est un peu comme tout à l'heure en
fait dans des 8 ça gai c'est pas le truc
il fait le
killing bleu comme on dit en anglais tu
feras B7 il y a pas deux échecs
et là du coup c'est de nouveau et il a
raté
[Musique]
j'imagine qu'il a dû dire que sur ton
rêve
ouais en plus
pour moi c'est le seul coup enfin
visuellement je parle
si tu le vois pas là tu arrêtes
à un coup qu'on avait
pour moi très bizarre
j'aurais jamais fait pas il a pas un
jour F5 il aura
c'est pas un mauvais coup mais genre son
rêve 7 surtout F7
est-ce que tu as mieux que revenir c'est
ça
je trouve ça très bizarre
c'est bizarre le roi plutôt au centre ça
avait l'air logique
je vais gagner cette finale
alors faut pas je te regarde
même ça ça serait pas encore amené tout
de suite mais
ça doit faire nul ouais je pense
on croit je suis très bizarre en tout
cas ce qu'il veut faire
sur ça il y aura du cavalier 5 qui
m'empêche un peu de progresser
a plus hein
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout le coup que je voulais
dire en plus
ça a aucun sens tu peux prendre
[Musique]
un sens
si je fais Kelly ce que tu me dis que tu
l'as empêché tu es sûr
en fait j'ai empêché
le 3 juillet
[Musique]
en E7 au lieu de 7 pour son cahier des 5
joueurs
[Musique]
c'est pas des finales pas très technique
très ouais c'est hier c'était plus plus
compliqué là c'est
beaucoup de calcul donc dame 6 va être
joué
pas vérifié mais bon
je peux plus bouger ma dame à cause de
ça
une
erreur il s'est fait punir dans une
ligne très compliquée théorie
de l'adversaire pour gagner quoi donc je
me dis ben tourner c'est logique
je garde la pression et
ce qui m'ont fait toujours s'envoyer ça
quoi les trucs à chaque fois
[Musique]
ce 19 minutes pour 13 coups
il y a moyen qui
se passe à voir un max
et après des fois hyper longtemps aussi
rien demain
grosse grosse partie en tout cas
à une Europe unie
en ligne
du coup ça joue encore un roi jiste
arrière Clichy donc là on avait dans le
chat planète qui nous dit cavalier pour
récupérer la chatte bah c'est peut-être
l'idée mais le problème c'est que
tu as pas forcément le temps sur ça
qu'elle valait fuite
le meilleur coup ok donc là il nous a un
petit peu réputé
5 maintenant je comprends pas vraiment
l'idée là tu vois c'est pas logique
d'avoir je rouage 6 pour jouera le 5 au
cours d'après
mais ok 5 vas-y juste pour rigoler
[Musique]
qui assiste en B4 mais juste c'est
tellement bizarre par faire Wolf 5 h 5
je sais pas
OK
[Musique]
je peux comprendre
quasiment en maths enfin pas mal mais tu
vois regarde
ça
je joue un coup au hasard
pardon
tac tac tac
t'as pas le temps non
il faut que je perde un temps
en fait
toi tu l'as eu peur de de ça en fait la
finale elle est elle est beaucoup plus
facile
en D7 j'ai du mal à jouer cavalier à 6
je vous en tant que faire avec mon
cavale
assise mais du coup que le cavalier ici
ça va être compliqué
mais la différence avec cavalier à 6
c'est qu'en fait plus tard
si tu veux manger Hachette avec et c'est
5 échecs je peux te contrôler
par exemple là
genre ça perd direct j'ai échec bon je
peux manger sur échec aussi mais on va
juste dire que je le fais pas juste pour
l'exemple là j'ai ça
et là j'ai ça
parce que du coup le cavalier contrôle
les deux cases est sorti en fait du
cavalier blanc
donc du coup en fait
maintenant on l'a dit tout à l'heure on
l'a dit
mais du coup oui c'est pour ça que du
coup le cavalier en 6 ça marche mais par
contre
ça marchait plus parce que je contrôle
plus les cadres en fait donc
si si ça ne paraît très clean dans tous
les cas
mais les gens c'est bizarre c'est pas du
tout dans l'esprit mais bon oui il a dû
avoir peur de ce qu'on a dit
[Musique]
oui
je sens
il va vouloir la gagner quand même
pas
ce qui peut changer
la fuite on était pas sûr de la finale
de mémoire on avait quatre
je pense qu'on avait
avec l'idée de
la vidéo
ah oui parce qu'il y avait le fameux
tomates en tout cas
je vais faire ça
tu manges ça et puis
[Musique]
et ouais 5 je pense que la finale gagne
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas sûr à 100
%
cavalier quoi mais juste un truc tout
bête genre ça et tout recap
va les prendre
[Musique]
les problèmes de partout j'ai du mal à
défendre en même temps il y a eu tout ça
dans la partie
on avait dit quoi sur
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait si tu fais que
vient de se terminer il y avait le title
c'est ça
là il y a Toro 6 je pense
jamais été aussi actif
S
désolé j'ai pas suivi le title
[Musique]
revenir
donc il ajoute dame B5
il est revenu de la maternité en forme
moi ils viennent m'écrire pour faire la
vidéo avec moi donc je la fais pas tout
seul demain
à 4 waouh non mais ce genre de coup
c'est une déviation c'est très très dur
à défendre en partie en partie tes maths
en fait
c'est trop dur
que ça va finir par craquer
il veut dévier donc là du coup sur d'un
point 4 ça perd à cause des chèques et
bon si tu vas ici tout simplement j'ai
chèque l'attaque la tour et il y a aussi
l'enfilade sur
la dame blanche en dessin contre toutes
les cases des échecs en fait c'est à
dire que par exemple sur un échec en F1
il y a pas d'échec sur case noire et sur
pareil un Damas échec il y a plus
d'échec parce que Madame contre le tour
en fait et là il a tout en l'air j'ai
des échecs de partout ça a 300 la
différence des rois c'est juste évident
maintenant
ok jolie du coup à 4 c'est bien joué et
du coup faut pas manger le pion c'est
interdit
faut que tu contrôles le pion C4 qui est
en prise il faut défendre ça et ça quoi
il y a pas de
c'est le plus logique mais c'est ça
[Musique]
dame ceci c'est le plus logique pour moi
pourquoi tu fais pas juste plus simple
tu peux pas venir sur la 6e
G5 j'y crois pas de son A4 tu veux dire
caille
tu dois rester en contact depuis
gagnant maintenant
C5 c'était le dernier coup pour moi qui
avait du sens du coup
parce que j'ai plus de passer
évident
[Musique]
ce n'est pas ça
je ne sais pas
parce qu'en fait il faut que je contrôle
tu me laisses ton dessin en fait
je perds
c'est peut-être son idée
mais là il doit y avoir un truc parce
qu'il a pas joué vite
non on n'est pas payé à l'heure
malheureusement
j'ai déjà été payé à l'heure mais pas là
cette fois et là
dans l'autre partie
[Musique]
le coup de la jauge la jauge se fâche
sur
des 7 il ajoute 5 ok donc on va voir
il est en bleu maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'il me raconte je l'ai essayé tout à
l'heure
en fait j'ai pas vu de défense depuis
tout à l'heure je cherche que tourner
cette tourbière
pour moi c'était le meilleur coup aussi
pour des 1 tomber un coup
pardon et pas proposer un moment de
vérité chèque d'abord
du coup là la menace c'est directement
de faire ça ça quoi voilà et si ton
dessert
le mail va partir je te lance
après
regarde le message d'erreur essaie de
voir
trois victoires en tout du coup
[Musique]
ça fait
un moment qu'il est qu'il est perdant
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait là
le coup aussi cavalier à 6 du coup ah
non là ça marche plus là
par exemple je sais pas si c'est le
meilleur mais en français
parce que c'est ton idée depuis le début
je vais te laisser là-dessus ça marche
bah écoute bonne soirée à toi et puis
merci
il y a encore deux trous je crois
mais je les ai les dates là c'est jeudi
et vendredi 27 vendredi 27 c'est pas
avec moi ce sera avec Kevin sérieux du
19 il y a pas école la grève donc c'est
ce sera avec moi sinon c'est le 27 qui
sera avec Kevin
vendredi 27
vendredi 27 tu me redis on en reparle en
privé
ça marche bonne soirée à toi à bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]
du coup on va partir sur la vue non j'ai
pris la mauvaise caméra là vous avez le
dos de param c'est pas non plus ce que
je voulais je vais tester mes caméras
voir ce que j'ai de beau à vous montrer
alors attendez un petit seconde
vous avez la partie en tout cas qui se
joue et moi je vais revenir sur mon truc
pour voir quelle caméra du coup j'avais
c'était laquelle
la 5 la caméra qui ont sauté c'est un
enfer
c'est un enfer caméra qui qui saute
et du coup la caméra De Jing je voulais
vu que c'est la partie qui risque de
durer parce que je n'ai pas de face
au Parame de dos
je pense que vous comprenez tous
alors c'est la 5 du coup que je voulais
elle a 5 je vais faire ça
et revenir ici
je peux mettre une grande caméra
peut-être ce sera mieux
je vais remettre celle-là je vais faire
ça je pense
attendez un je règle tout
je pense ça peut être sympa de mettre
cette vue là vous me dites ce que vous
en pensez
ça arrive
une seconde
que pensez-vous de cette vue là
je pense c'est pas mal
ça arrive car celle qui a qui a perdu
contre
car scène qui a perdu donc on voit pas
bien échiquier mais on voit en tout cas
Ding j'ai pas mieux je prends en terme
de caméra pour l'instant je vais check
une petite seconde et mes caméras elles
sont un petit peu à l'agonie
j'ai rien de vraiment
rien vraiment très très bien
ça
j'ai que quatre caméras malheureusement
et j'enlève ça
j'en ai que 4 qui marche
attends
je vais y arriver
et c'est celle-là
en fait là j'ai une meilleure caméra
attendez ça arrive
sur celle là que pensez-vous du coup de
cette vue là
je pense que vous y pensez rien parce
que la caméra a sauté assez horrible
désolé
ma caméra elle est bien et puis elle
saute je crois qu'elle est revenue
la caméra sautant mes caméras sautent
mais je crois que j'ai réussi à remettre
une bonne une bonne caméra cette fois-ci
non j'ai envie la même
est-ce que je suis débile car c'est non
inversé par par
[Musique]
Guy et du coup d'ailleurs
et du coup
[Musique]
à bout cette Europe qui peut rattraper
guéri en cas de victoire
donc là on a on a pratique en train de
faire c'est sa grosse partie
contreding partie impressionnante je
vous rappelle que Prague il a seulement
17 ans
et
il va venir à bout sûrement de du numéro
de mondial digne qui jouera d'ailleurs
le match championnat du monde contre
népo en avril
il est combien mais il est loin il est
loin parce que maintenant du coup il se
dépassé un peu partout de monde on fera
le on fera le point bechy à la fin de la
ronde parce que là il y a encore deux
parties en cours donc ça ça veut rien
dire le score lâche
donc il s'est passé quoi dans la partie
de Abdou il y a eu tourner le bon
couteau bien le bon coup
dame j'essaie de tour B2 et dames B2 une
claque des menaces de de quasiment
je vais juste
raccrocher mes appels avec
avec
[Musique]
Mathieu qui est parti
donc on verra après je sais pas encore
au niveau des trucs la roi Sétif ça a
été joué par parram
et chez moi ça apparaît tout rouge
c'est les parties sur quel format c'est
des parties lentes ils ont beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à la pendule donc
ça peut durer très très longtemps là ils
ont encore à la pendule donc la partie
qu'on a devant les yeux là c'est la
partie de pragranda contre
dingly Rennes numéro 2 mondial Prague à
7 minutes contre 15 et dans 10 coups là
on est au 50e coup et dans 10 coups les
deux joueurs auront un quart d'heure
supplémentaire pour terminer la partie
donc faut savoir aussi que les gens ont
toujours 30 secondes par coup en du
début jusqu'à la fin
on va manger les pions bouger la tour
pousser les pions salades
en plus il y a aussi des thèmes de maths
avec trois les cinq C4 ça peut être être
matin il y a plein d'idées ici pour les
Noirs je pense que je pense que Prague
va gagner
en tout cas j'espère à marcher pour
Prague je suis pour la jeunesse
donc dame B8 a été joué donc en même
temps l'autre partie celle de Abdou
contre parram donc parrain n'a plus que
6 minutes à la pendule pour jouer encore
7 coups pour avoir son incrément
donc 6 minutes pour cette coups dans une
position hyper dur à défendre
je peux voir c'est une caméra sur Param
mais je suis pas sûr que j'en ai
je suis pas sûr que j'en ai
j'en ai une sur Abdou
mes parents je vois pas trop
mettre en plus petit
et du coup
je crois que c'est la neuf attendez
la caméra je crois que c'était la neuf
je la neuf je vais la prendre
je vais vous mettre la caméra aussi
comme ça on pourra switcher je pense
entre les deux
je vais mettre la 9 pour pouvoir
switcher
entre les deux
quasi bon
c'est la 9
c'est normal
du coup là vous avez la caméra de de
Ding qui est ici mais je peux aussi vous
mettre la caméra de de
[Musique]
parram où il est en train d'essayer de
trouver
de trouver des défenses c'est hyper
difficile hyper compliqué
caméra qui va arriver
donc par un petit qui est pas bien
tour D3 qui veut essayer de trouver des
15%
mais là il y a des sacs de partout
dans le bc3b6
se balader ça a l'air très difficile en
tout cas pour pour
donc il a répondu trois
là où il y a un petit peu l'expression
un petit peu des joueurs la motivation
du jour qu'elle est blanche qui qui est
vraiment redresser sur sa chaise
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer sur le
tour des trois
et après un coup qu'on a bien dame B7
comment on continue à prévoir 5
c'est clair il est vraiment moi je
trouve qu'il est classe
avec les Blancs
[Musique]
ça a l'air ça a l'air dur
ça a l'air très dur le roi qui se balade
mais on n'a pas encore la suite
on va des 6 ça a été joué
on les voit à la caméra là
il a mangé à 6 ok très bien aussi je
pense
sur le roi le saint qui avait le clouage
donc
il espère pouvoir se couvrir avec tourbe
peut-être
enfin la 8e maintenant je pense pas
cette partie là je pense qu'elle va
mettre bientôt se terminer et
la partie de Prague elle a l'argagnante
donc on va voir après ce qui se passe
après si tu me si tu m'accompagnes
Robinson avec grand plaisir ça va être
très très grand plaisir si tu veux
m'accompagner
tu as dit que tu préfères les jeunes ben
non mais en fait
par de la jeunesse montante Ding il a
déjà fait ses preuves les numéros de
mondial
je l'ai connu quand il avait 14 ans il
est connu personnellement ce qu'on a
fait un stage en Inde chez contre lui
quand il avait 13 ou 14 ans quand je
l'ai connu et
donc
du coup voilà je le connais
personnellement il a fait le peine de
Cannes là où j'habite quand il avait 12
ans il a fait sa première disant pardon
fait sa première norme de maître à 10
ans il avait il avait
2000 et l'eau
il a demandé une dérogation pour jouer
pour jouer à l'Open a
150 mondial pas mal
je pense qu'il est mis il est mieux que
ça quoi en 5 millièmes peut-être et
encore regarder après
du coup donc du coup
Abdou qui se prend pas la tête vous
voyez
il prend les pions
et il continue en plus à attaquer donc
la tour B7 c'était juste une grosse
menace là il y a deux pions d'avance il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de de réseau de
map possible là et du tour 1 du Tour B7
c'est très très dur pour les blancs
c'est juste beaucoup trop dur
alors que Ding Prague je regarde en plus
à côté c'est un peu plus long donc celle
là je pense vraiment d'une priorité
parce que on arrive à la fin de la
partie il y a peu de temps pour les
Noirs il reste quatre coups à jouer
avant d'arriver au
en rajoutant du 15 coups
mais est-ce qu'il va est-ce qu'il va
réussir à y arriver avant de commettre
une faute parce que là le roi noir a
l'air complètement muselé
merci à
ouais
il avait la tête il avait les mains
comme ça j'ai
envie de récupérer ce que j'avais dit
mais
elles seront plus la tête vous voyez il
se prend plus la tête d'où il a fini
alors du coup roi décès donc tour B7 a
l'air encore un coup normal mais
attention contre le jeu parce que par
exemple on peut y avoir quoi c'est 8
attaque la tour et quand je bouge ma
tour eh ben il pourrait avoir du Tour
d'1 celui de dame j'ai un échec il y a
un petit contre jeu qui peut arriver
avec avec les Noirs donc faut vraiment
faire attention en tout cas
peut-être tout F1 alors très bien pour
venir ici
et continue à attaquer
semble mort
humblement il y a trois pions d'avance
droit qui est toujours aussi faible peu
de temps à la pendule
ça semble très très dur pour le noir
salut Shadows il est pas bien
et digne non plus il est pas bien
j'ai 21 ans et quasi 1900 élo en blitz
sur chess com sachant qu'on est jamais
été en club j'ai tout appris en tout cas
depuis presque 10 ans j'aimerais savoir
si la première progression est encore
possible à quel point comment merci
d'avance
parce qu'une bonne question
bien sûr je pense que tu peux toujours
progresser par toi-même après c'est
clair que
travailler tout seul bon maintenant il y
a quand même pas mal de de
matériel sur internet pour travailler
les déchets tu as plein de vidéos tu as
les streams les YouTube et j'en passe tu
vois donc il y a moyen encore de pouvoir
travailler tout seul et progresser c'est
clair mais après c'est clair que quand
on a ton niveau peut-être que avoir un
coach serait peut-être aussi quelque
chose d'intéressant qui pourrait te
booster un petit peu et te montrer un
peu comment on travaille etc
pour te guider aussi c'est une idée
c'est intéressant mais sinon oui je
pense que tu peux encore travailler
encore progresser en travaillant tout
seul et
il y a des limites quand même dans
après ça dépend vraiment de toi je pense
et chacun est différent tu vois chacun a
ses limites on va dire mais déjà c'est
pas mal ce que tu fais 1900
club ni prix de course c'est quand même
intéressant
mais en fait disons que tu as des gens
qui sont spécialistes dans le domaine
qui peuvent t'aider à
aller un peu plus vite dans
l'apprentissage quoi
donc là du coup Dame des 5 menace
tourner un des fois et en plus aussi tu
reprends un choix attention qu'il y a
toujours le vis-à-vis il arrive donc
voilà
bon après
après c'est clair que
que
faut avoir les moyens de se payer de ce
pays un coach c'est encore autre chose
mais même sans ça vous avez quand même
pas mal de d'infos vous avez des vous
avez des
vidéos youtube il y a plein de chaînes
intéressantes donc si vous parlez
anglais c'est encore encore mieux il y a
vraiment plein plein de trucs
intéressants sur internet
il y a plein de sites juste vous avez
tout ce qu'il faut pas tout ce qu'il
faut sur internet pour pouvoir
plein plein de stream aussi très sympa
d'ailleurs j'en profite parce que j'ai
pas encore fait la pub mais vous savez
que je stream
et j'ai ma propre chaîne c'est pas Fatou
tu veux me faire un petit saut s'il te
plaît parce que je ne peux pas me faire
de sauts malheureusement
à moi-même mais je stream régulièrement
sur twitch moi ça fait un moment que que
le stream plus trop trop parce que je
stream beaucoup sur chaise comme FR et
j'ai pas eu le temps de revenir sur ma
chaîne mais ça va revenir très bientôt
quel troll alors mais du coup je stream
sur sur
twitch donc c'est stouf et j'ai aussi ma
chaîne youtube donc pour ceux qui
voudraient venir voir un peu ce que je
fais comme contenu merci et Fatou et ben
j'ai j'ai ma chaîne youtube si tu fais
chèque n'hésitez pas à aller voir en ce
moment je fais un Raoul to Amy et je
suis aussi un road enfin speedrun où je
je peine à passer les 1300 et lots voilà
[Rires]
j'ai pas lu du coup merci beaucoup j'ai
déjà pensé à un coach ou de rejoindre un
club pour progresser alors c'est clair
que rejoindre un club c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très important pour toi
je pense que tu verras qu'avant une
différence entre leur entre le
l'internet c'est le club quoi c'est
c'est vraiment vraiment cool ou pas
un budgétaire encore étudiant et sans
revenu donc pour le moment le travail
des livres et des vidéos de magazines
yes bon après tu vois
je sais pas dans quel point tu habites
mais
un club
juste pour aller jouer de temps en temps
c'est sympa quoi voir des gens parler
échec c'est quand même quelque chose de
pas mal quoi après une fois que tu as un
club tu peux aussi faire des tournois en
IRL et ça c'est quand même
différent même pas mal progresser grâce
au tournoi IRL quoi vraiment important
attention que là c'est mats
aura toujours de grosses lacunes des
livres polissage ouais bon après après
voilà mais mais déjà un mec qui est
autodidacte qui est capable de
travailler tout seul et ça c'est déjà
quelque chose de de bien et des fois
rare parce qu'il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup de joueurs qui travaillent pas
assez les échecs malheureusement
comment je peux comprendre ouais c'est
beaucoup de chance en fait Claudius
non en fait bah oui bah écoutez moi je
sais que depuis j'ai 6 ans donc
les échecs c'est c'est un peu ma vie
quoi donc
donc voilà quoi et une logique après
chaque coup après bien sûr ne vous
inquiétez pas je ne comprends pas tout
non plus ça c'est clair mais après j'ai
lancé de comprendre la logique après
avec Mathieu on a aussi on a aussi la
jauge que vous n'êtes pas mal
pour comprendre mais du coup c'est
logique et c'est intéressant
merci pour le follow du coup
pas 2006 pas loin pas loin
ben non ma maman les patristes
au contraire au moment j'ai ma voix
quand tu peux travailler de ta passion
généralement
c'est plutôt positif quoi voilà
donc moi je suis très satisfait de la
voix que j'ai pris en tout cas avec
Claudius le fait de faire de même un
travail de ta passion un jour je sais
pas si tu en as une mais en tout cas
mais en tout cas je te souhaite de
travailler de ta passion c'est rare hein
de nos jours de travailler travailler
comme ça donc j'ai 5 ça va être mature
et le mode du couloir qui va arriver
et ça va être le match de l'escalier et
sur du coup dame ici je vais avoir tout
réussi je pense qu'il va au moins gagner
peut-être même mieux d'ailleurs pas sûr
donc donc avoir
bonne soirée
à bientôt
donc du coup on a la grosse partie en
tout cas de de Abdou qui avait raté les
choses dans la partie à un moment donné
plusieurs plusieurs gains
il avait raté des gants et du coup du
coup elle mérité je pense être parti
dame 7 et là on va voir du coup
quasiment en direct je pense l'abandon
de param dans cette partie
on terminera du coup sur la partie de
Prague
avec le grand écran
du coup dame cette échec
mais sur sur ça ça va gagner je pense
tranquille
d'apprendre échec je peux encore pousser
mon pion lui aussi mais bon j'ai une
dame et un pion une case de la dame
contre une tour et un pion c'est quand
même
[Musique]
quand même assez assez facile
la tour la gagne après il y a peut-être
un match aussi hein
il y a peut-être mieux
avoir un
un tour des uns
effectivement je croyais que tu me
trollais mais il y a match Yamaha oui
encore une fois voilà ce qui se passe
quand on
avec Mathieu on a pris l'habitude de
vraiment tout faire sans ordinateur donc